Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wir blicken auf die 2. Bundesliga, der Männer wollen uns heute auseinandersetzen mit Fortuna, Düsseldorf, Arminia Bielefeld und Hansa Rostock. Und das alles passiert hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 258. Ich grüße euch liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schön, dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt. Hier ist der Kurzpass und wir wollen heute sprechen über die 2. Liga. Und dazu begrüße ich euch ganz herzlich. Mein Name ist Max-Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Im Grunde gibt es eigentlich fast allen Fußball-Content nur noch dort, nicht mehr auf Twitter. Und ich freue mich, dass ich jetzt drei Gäste hier habe. Zum einen die Stimme der 2. Liga, Eva-Lotte Bohle vom 2. Bundesliga-Pod. Eigentlich muss ich sie gar nicht vorstellen. Nur pro forma, sie heißt auch Eva Bohle auf Twitter. Schön, dass du hier bist, liebe Eva.
Ich habe sogar auch Mastodon, aber da bin ich noch nicht so ganz.
Welche Instanz denn, Eva?
Hier am Mastodon.Social.
Ja, die gute Instanz. Sehr gut.
Ja, ich bin euch der Gruppe gefolgt. Das, was mir am leichtesten vorkam. Nein, aber freut mich sehr, dass ich hier sein darf, wie immer für die Einladung und auch in einer sehr guten Runde.
Aber absolut und Teil dieser Runde ist unter anderem Lukas vom Fortuna Düsseldorf Podcast aus dem Exil. Als ad aus Exil kann man dem Podcast auch auf Twitter folgen und damit auch indirekt Lukas. Hallo Lukas, schön, dass du wieder im Rasenfunk bist.
Ja, hallo. Danke für die Einladung. Und vielleicht auch noch mal eine gute Erinnerung, dass wir auch mit dem Podcast vielleicht mal zumindest auch zweigleisig fahren sollten und mal langsam das Thema Mastodon angehen müssen.
Ja, mein Tag ist tatsächlich lieber früher als später. Zumindest bei mir funktionieren viele Funktionen von Twitter schon nicht mehr so richtig. Das merken, glaube ich, manche Accounts ein bisschen früher als andere. Ich konnte zum Beispiel neulich ein Video, das ich zu meiner Lesung in Ulm gemacht habe, übrigens am 20. April, also am Donnerstag, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer aus dem Großraum Ulm. Das konnte ich nicht hochladen, in zehn Versuchen. Es ging dann nur über die offizielle Twitter-App, die ich natürlich dafür extra installieren musste. Dann habe ich sie wieder deinstalliert. Das hat sich gelohnt. Das war jetzt eine Ex-Kurs, die niemand gebraucht hat. Die Nächsten braucht es aber unbedingt, denn ich möchte euch noch Oliver Leiste vorstellen. Er ist unter anderem beim MDR. Da hat er auch eigene Podcasts. Er ist der Ed Leiste und ist heute unser Hansa Rostock Experte. Hallo Olli, schön, dass du hier bist. Hast du es vom Training noch pünktlich hierher geschafft? Wir grüßen dich unbekannt. Das Trainingsmitglied, das auch den Rasenfunk hört. Schön, dass du den Olli noch rechtzeitig losgehst. Hast lassen. Und es hat auch fast pünktlich geklappt. Mehr möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen. Bevor wir loslegen, möchte ich aber noch darauf hinweisen, der Rasenfunk ist allein von euch finanziert, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich habe neulich wieder jemandem das Modell des Rasenfunks erklärt. Ich habe ihm unglaubliche Augen geschaut. Also, es war erst schon, als ich gesagt habe, was mein Beruf ist, sehr unglaublich, staunend. Und dann, dass das Ganze eben von euch finanziert wird, da wurde die Pupille noch größer, um es mal so zu sagen. Bitte unterstützt uns auf Rasenfunk.de slash supportersclub. Erfahrt ihr, wie man das tun kann. Ihr könnt das auch tun, indem ihr unseren Merch kauft unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de. Das ist ein bisschen eingeschlafen zuletzt, weiß gar nicht. Vielleicht habe ich zu wenig Werbung dafür gemacht. kiosk.rasenfunk.de, da gibt es Merch. Auch damit könnt ihr uns unterstützen. Aber das soll jetzt reichen. Jetzt wollen wir mal auf diese 2. Männer-Bundesliga blicken. 28 Spieltage sind gespielt. Und wir beginnen mal mit einem ganz kurzen Update, was so seit dem letzten Mal passiert ist. Unter anderem, Eva haben eigentlich fast alle verloren, die da oben drin hängen. Was ist da los?
Es möchte einfach niemand diese tolle Liga verlassen.
Das ist wirklich so.
Nein, es ist ja irgendwie, wir sagen immer jedes Jahr, die Liga ist super spannend und super knapp. Ich finde tatsächlich im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr, ich glaube für zwei von uns aus etwas leitender Sicht auch im Abstiegskampf um einiges enger als letztes Jahr, aber eben auch obenrum und immer, dass halt so spät in der Saison auch wieder neue Mitspieler quasi so ein bisschen dazukommen in diesem Ausstiegskampf oder auch Mannschaften, von denen man dachte, ja, okay, das wird es jetzt gewesen sein oder so, dass die dann doch immer noch mitmischen, das macht die Liga natürlich aus. Und ich glaube, von außen halt immer sehr interessant und halt nie langweilig für Fans der Vereine, die sowohl oben als auch unten dabei sind. Sehr anstrengend, das kann ich aus Erfahrung sagen, aber ja, es ist viel passiert und ich glaube, gerade dieses Wochenende haben wir eine Partie einfach, die, glaube ich, keiner von uns so erwartet hat, dass sie diese Brisanz haben wird mit dem Hamburg Derby. Es wurde ja ein bisschen Brisanz rausgenommen, dadurch, dass St. Pauli verloren hat, eben der HSV auch. Also ich glaube, selbst dann wäre es unwahrscheinlich gewesen, dass St. Pauli am HSV vorbeizieht, weil einfach der Tor-Differenz dann doch durchaus, also ich glaube, dann hätte St. Pauli irgendwie zwölf Tore schießen müssen in den zwei Spielen und keins kassieren oder so ähnlich. Das ist dann doch ein bisschen unwahrscheinlich. Aber ja, das hat so ein bisschen die Brisanz genommen, aber ist natürlich trotzdem immer noch da, dass St. Pauli mit einem Sieg am Freitagabend drei Punkte an den HSV ranrücken könnte.
Das war eins der überraschenden Ergebnisse. St. Pauli verliert zu Hause gegen auch noch Eintracht Braunschweig. Das ist Teil dessen, dass es da unten im Tabellenkeller jetzt nochmal ein bisschen kuscheliger geworden ist. Die Serie von St. Pauli, sie ist also vorbei und Lukas, die ganzen alten HSV-Witze werden wieder rausgepackt und so weiter. Ich habe neulich mit jemandem über die zweite Liga gesprochen, die sehr HSV-nah ist, um es mal so zu sagen. Die geht fest davon aus, dass das auf gar keinen Fall wieder klappt mit dem Aufstieg. Ich dachte, dass das vielleicht dieses Jahr wieder nur ein Meme ist, an das wir uns alle gewöhnt haben. Aber nachdem du ja als Düsseldorf-Fan in unmittelbarer Nachbarschaft guckst, was die oberen drei da machen und vielleicht ja auch darauf hoffst, dass da der eine oder andere noch stolpert. Was ist denn so dein Gefühl, was eben jetzt so Darmstadt-Heidenheim den HSV angeht?
Ja, also mein Gefühl ist auf jeden Fall, dass Darmstadt und Heidenheim das ziemlich sicher machen würden. Nicht zuletzt durch das Darmstädter Spiel, das ich jetzt ja gestern in Düsseldorf gesehen habe.
Da haben sie dich so überzeugt, oder? Ja, haben sie aus Darmstädter Sicht.
Haben sie wirklich. Also das hat auch der Düsseldorfer Trainer Daniel Thun in der Pressekonferenz hinterher nochmal gesagt, dass sie in Darmstadt extrem beeindruckt hat und dass sie da auf jeden Fall auch den Sieg verdient gehabt hätten. Die hatten die besseren Chancen, die waren wirklich eigentlich auch das ganze Spiel am Drücker. Ich habe wirklich noch keine Mannschaft gesehen, die sich in Düsseldorf so stark vorgestellt hat. Diese Saison muss ich ganz klar sagen. Auf der anderen Seite dieses Gefühl hatte ich vom HSV in der Hinrunde ehrlicherweise auch. Da ist Düsseldorf ziemlich fies bahnen gegangen und die sahen wirklich super stark aus, haben gespielt wie aus einem Guss und da war ich mit total Sicherheit, dass dann dieses furchtbare Meme, dass er eigentlich schon so unglaublich alt und so unglaublich schlecht ist, dass der HSV einfach immer wieder vergeigt, dass es dann endlich mal der Vergangenheit angehört. Aber jetzt langsam muss man dann vielleicht sich doch wieder damit beschäftigen und weil ich auch nicht so wirklich mit dem Sieg der Fortuna gegen Darmstadt gerechnet habe, ist auch eigentlich erst seit gestern wieder so wirklich meine Aufmerksamkeit mit mehr als einem halben Auge beim Aufstiegskampf, muss ich sagen.
Also über die Fortuna werden wir gleich länger sprechen. Es ist aktuell ebenso, Darmstadt 58 Punkte, Heidenheim 54, die konnten gewinnen bei Hannover 96, der HSV 53 und Düsseldorf und St. Pauli jeweils 47 und dahinter Paderborn mit 46. Die sind 7 Punkte bzw. 6 Punkte entfernt vom dritten Rang und wir wissen ja unter anderem St. Pauli und HSV werden entweder nicht vollständig punkten oder einer von beiden auch Punkte lassen jetzt dann am nächsten Spieltag. Und unten drin, Olli, da ist ja auch so einiges passiert. Also wir werden ja noch über Rostock ausführlicher sprechen, aber St. Hausen zum Beispiel, Trainerwechsel, Braunschweig, jetzt gewonnen, ist auch noch alles muckelig, eng beieinander.
Definitiv ja und vielleicht anschließend an das, was Eva gesagt hatte mit dieser engen Liga und jeder kann jeden schlagen und so weiter. Ich habe immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, aus der dritten Liga kennt man das auch. So die die erste Halbserie ist immer die der Aufstiegskandidaten und die zweite Halbserie oder das das letzte Saisondrittel, besser gesagt, ist immer das so der Abschiegskandidaten, also wo es dann naja ganz oft zu beobachten ist, dass die Mannschaften oben sich nicht so richtig trauen oder Angst haben, dann tatsächlich durchzuziehen, während die unten dann irgendwie nochmal Luft bekommen oder irgendwas verändern beim Trainer, beim Kader. Und dann so mit dem Mute der Verzweiflung, sagt man glaube ich so schön, dann plötzlich anfangen Spiele zu gewinnen, was man ja vorher nicht unbedingt erwartet hätte. Ich denke Eintracht Braunschweig gegen St. Pauli ist so ein Beispiel, wobei man sicherlich, wir uns ja auch alle einig sind, dass es endlich mal wieder Zeit war, dass sie auch ein Spiel verlieren. Also jetzt die perfekte Rückrunde hätte ich ihnen ehrlicherweise dann doch nicht gegönnt. Ja, Sandhausen gegen Magdeburg. Magdeburg eigentlich zuletzt sehr stark gewesen, aber das Spiel habe ich über weite Teile verfolgt. Das war ein verdienter Sieg von Sandhausen. Mit vielen Näglichkeiten das Spiel der Magdeburger, die ja wirklich gerne auf Fußball spielen wollen, unterbunden und dann nach zwei Standardtoren da zum Sieg gekommen.
Das wusste ich gar nicht. Ich habe das gar nicht gesehen, die Tore. Das ist ja S. Sandhausen, S. It's Get. Also so ein bisschen Vintage Sandhausen, so ein bisschen, so wie früher.
Absolut, ja. Ja, gut, die anderen Spiele, da waren jetzt nicht ganz so viele Überraschungen dabei, dass Jahn Regensburg gegen Greuther Fürth verliert, ist so wie die Fürther zuletzt drauf waren, jetzt auch nicht ganz überraschend. Insofern, ja, waren das sicherlich die beiden Spiele, die da so ein bisschen im Blickpunkt standen und klar, wenn wir über Hansa reden, dass sie gegen Paderborn verlieren, kam nicht überraschend und dass sie nach der frühen roten Karte sehr hoch verlieren, kam leider auch nicht überraschend.
Ich würde einmal kurz bei dem Regensburg-Fürth-Spiel einhaken, weil ich also das leider für Regensburg dann in in einer Art und Weise doch ein bisschen unglücklich war, weil das jetzt glaube ich das zweite oder dritte Spiel war, wo sie nicht unbedingt die schlechtere Mannschaft waren und führt ähnlich glaube ich auch im Spiel. War es nicht sogar entweder, ich glaube es war Magdeburg, wo sie auch nur sehr schlecht der erste Hälfte hatten, dann sehr effizient in der zweiten Halbzeit war. Es war in dem Spiel meiner Meinung nach ähnlich. Also es hätte auch, hätte Regensburg seine Chancen etwas besser genutzt, hätte das auch Regensburg gewinnen können, glaube ich. Also deshalb, ich glaube da blendet das Ergebnis ein bisschen vom tatsächlichen Spielverlauf.
Da würde ich jetzt aber für das Spiel gegen Magdeburg widersprechen wollen. Da war der FCM aus meiner Sicht schon klar die bessere Mannschaft und unser Tenor im FCM-Podcast beim MDR war dann so ein bisschen, dass der FCM da auf jeden Fall die Punkte verschenkt hat. Also dass Regensburg dann zwar natürlich sehr fleißig sich gewehrt hat, auch zu Toren gekommen ist, aber – Nein, ich meinte bei Führt gegen Magdeburg, sorry.
Da habe ich falsch ausgedrückt. Nein, das Führt-Magdeburg-Spiel war auch das Führt eine relativ schlechte 1. Halbzeit hatte, da gab es auch die Pfiffe in der Halbzeit. Und dann, dass das Führt das dann hinterher doch gewonnen hat und das hier aber ähnlich war, dass man zu Hause erst eine nicht so gute 1. Halbzeit hatte und dann einfach effizient in der 2. sorry.
Du arbeitest ja bloß wieder am nächsten Kurzpass, in dem wir hier auch Michael Fischer wieder sitzen haben und dich natürlich. Das ist ja die feste Kombination. Aber dafür, es führt jetzt gerade ein bisschen zu wenig Drama. Jetzt mit 36 Punkten ist man neun Punkte vor dem Relegationsplatz. Also relativ sicher raus da unten. Das kann man dann, glaube ich, als Unbeteiligter zumindest schon so sagen. Aber dann lasst mal in eure Vereine näher reingehen, nachdem wir jetzt schon gelernt haben. Also es ist alles ein bisschen gestaucht von oben und von unten und noch nichts entschieden. Dementsprechend hat auch die Fortuna eben die Möglichkeit, Lukas, dass man da oben wieder eingreifen könnte. Und das hat man, wir haben es ja jetzt schon kurz thematisiert, dadurch unter anderem sich ermöglicht, dass man jetzt den SV Darmstadt, also den amtierenden Spitzenreiter geschlagen hat mit 1 zu 0. Was wären denn die Gründe dafür, dass man vielleicht einen Aufstieg schaffen würde? Das ist jetzt ganz schön viel konjunktiv. Warum seid ihr so gut? Ja, ist mir da auch aufgefallen, dass das ganz schön offensiv formuliert war.
Also da ist schon durchaus was dran. Die Fortuna hat sich jetzt gerade in den letzten Spielen ziemlich stabilisiert und ist seit zwei Monaten jetzt umgeschlagen. Man könnte vielleicht sogar fast sagen, dass das Erweckungserlebnis war. Die wirklich ziemlich bittere Pokalniederlage im Achtelfinale beim 1. Ja, und seitdem hat man sich wirklich stabilisiert und fährt da wirklich ein paar Punkte ein. Das hängt auch damit zusammen, dass, glaube ich, Thoune das allererste Mal in der Saison ein System gefunden hat, das zum Kader zu passen scheint. Ja, so ein 4-4-2 mit Doppel-6. Also gar nichts aufregendes eigentlich. Aber ich glaube, das ist eigentlich gerade auch bei uns in der Anhängerschaft relativ unbemerkt von Starten gegangen, weil ich glaube, wir Dislaver haben uns sehr stark auf die Heimenspiele gegen Heidenheim, HSV und jetzt eben auf das gegen Darmstadt konzentriert. In der Winterpause wurde da schon richtig stark hingeschaut, weil eigentlich die ganze Saison die Erzählung durchzogen hat, dass die Fortuna nicht in der Lage ist, Spitzenspiele zu gewinnen. Jetzt muss ich vielleicht auch so ein bisschen erklären, was ich damit meine. Also die Fortuna hat am zweiten Spieltag gegen Paderborn gewonnen mit 2 zu 1. Damals war vielleicht noch nicht so richtig vorauszusehen, oder zumindest war vielleicht vorauszusehen, dass das so eine Art Spitzenspiel werden könnte von zwei Mannschaften, die um den Aufstieg mitspielen. Aber an einem zweiten Spieltag, glaube ich, hat das vielleicht noch nicht so die Strahlkraft und die Bedeutung, wie wenn man weiß, wo es in der Saison eigentlich hingeht. Alle acht anderen, in der Folge hat man gegen alle Mannschaften, die oben standen, und das war wirklich achtmal in Folge, hat man eben nicht gewinnen können und hat sogar in der ganzen Hinterrunde alle Spiele verloren, gegen Heidenheim, gegen Hamburg, gegen Darmstadt. Man kann jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen lachen am 16. Spieltag gegen Hannover. Die waren damals in der Tat noch im Aufstiegskampf dabei. Und dann drei Tage später auch noch gegen Kaiserslautern, die beide damals dann, dadurch vor Fortuna, auch in der Hinterrunden-Tabelle standen und so in den Winter gegangen sind.
Und wenn man kezerisch sein würde, dann könnte man sagen, gewinnen tut man jetzt ja auch noch nicht gegen die Spitzen-Teams. Waren das jetzt nicht alles unentschieden? Gegen Heidenheim 1 zu 1, gegen den HSV 2 zu 2. Gut, und jetzt halt dann dieser Sieg gegen Darmstadt.
Also das ist nicht mal kezerisch, das ist absolut das, wie das, glaube ich, auch einfach wahrgenommen wurde. Und ich habe gerade dieses Spiel gegen Heidenheim fast schon wie so eine Art Endspiel deklariert, weil man dachte, okay, da könnte man nochmal den Rückstand. Ich glaube, von 7 auf 4 Punkte verkürzen hat das dann nicht geschafft. Und danach war zumindest so in der Anhängerschaft, finde ich, so eine Art Spannungsverlust halt irgendwie merkbar. Man hat dann das Spiel danach gegen Rostock gewonnen mit 5 zu 2. Ich glaube, der Olli wird sich da wahrscheinlich noch relativ gut dran erinnern, mit wie wenig Gegenwehr das eigentlich gewesen ist. Und hat dann gegen den HSV auch wieder den Rückstand nicht verringern können. Und ich glaube, aller spätestens da hat sich eigentlich keiner mehr wirklich Hoffnung gemacht. Und das hat sich wirklich eigentlich erst gestern so ein bisschen geändert, würde ich sagen. Eben mit diesem Sieg gegen Darmstadt.
Und wie würdest du sagen, hat sich die Fortuna jetzt entwickelt? Also wir hatten jetzt leider schon länger keinen Schwerpunkt mehr zu Düsseldorf hier im Rasenfunk. Ich glaube, in der letzten Saison war es das letzte Mal so, dass wir uns länger damit beschäftigt haben. Ich persönlich mag Daniel Chun. Ich weiß nicht, ob es daran liegt, dass ich zu wenige Interviews von ihm sehe. Aber ich habe den noch nie was richtig doofes Sagen hören oder auch irgendwie finde seine Art immer sehr angenehm. Dennoch hatte ich aus der Entfarnung auch ein bisschen den Eindruck, was sich jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen widergespiegelt hat in dem, was du gesagt hast. Man hat sich so ein bisschen damit arrangiert, dass man im oberen Drittel steht, aber man erlaubt sich selber nicht mehr so zu träumen. Vielleicht auch, weil das eben schon zu oft schiefgegangen ist in der jüngeren Vergangenheit. Wie blickst du denn auf den bisherigen Saisonverlauf und das, was sich bei der Fortuna insgesamt getan hat?
Ja, also Thuene ist auf jeden Fall ein ganz wichtiger Faktor. Der hatte bestimmt keine einfache Aufgabe, als er letztes Jahr während der Saison hierher gekommen ist. Hat die Fortuna dann relativ bravourös in der Liga gehalten. Und deswegen hat man sich eigentlich auch relativ große Hoffnungen gemacht, dass man wirklich auch um den Aufstieg mitspielen könnte diese Saison. Es gab dann viel Verletzungspech. Das finde ich eigentlich nicht so ein wirklich gutes Argument, um sich dafür zu entschuldigen, dass es irgendwie vielleicht mit dem Saisonziel nicht so ganz gereicht hat. Aber es war wirklich relativ viel in dieser Saison. Also das muss man wirklich mal heranführen. Und deswegen ist mit Sicherheit ein großer Faktor, warum es jetzt ein bisschen besser läuft, dass 2 zum ersten Mal mehr oder weniger aus dem Vollen schöpfen kann. Oder zumindest konnte. Also mittlerweile gibt es auch schon wieder den ein oder anderen wirklich wichtigen Ausfall. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr so dramatisch, wie es irgendwie noch in der Hinrunde gewesen ist. Und ein weiterer Grund, warum es jetzt auch einfach mittlerweile besser läuft, ist, glaube ich, dass man diese lange Vorbereitungszeit im Winter hatte. Man hat im Sommer zum wiederholten Mal erst sehr, sehr spät die Transfers getätigt. Also es gab da wirklich ein paar Zahlen, die ich wirklich ziemlich interessant fand. Also Fortuna war der letzte Verein von allen Zweitligisten, der im Sommer einen Spieler verpflichtet hat. Es waren zu dem Zeitpunkt, als Fortuna die erste Neuverpflichtung vorstellen konnte, schon 100 Spieler insgesamt neu verpflichtet worden in der 2. Liga. Paderborn zum Beispiel hatte da schon 10 Neuzugänge vorgestellt. Und es gab halt durchaus auch einige Baustellen, die geschlossen werden mussten, und die dann eben teilweise erst sehr spät geschlossen wurden oder teilweise auch gar nicht geschlossen wurden. Also, der sich noch an die letzte Saison erinnert, der kann sich vielleicht noch vor Augen rufen, wie unglaublich wichtig Carlet Nahrei für die Fortuna gewesen ist mit seiner Geschwindigkeit, dass man den natürlich nicht eins zu eins ersetzen kann. Ja, das war glaube ich allen klar. Letztendlich hat man die dabei einfach gar nicht ersetzt. Also man ist eigentlich nur mit drei offensiven Flügelspielern für zwei Positionen in die Saison gegangen. Und hat zum Beispiel gar nicht geschaut, dass man noch mal jemanden holt, der schnell ist. Also ich habe mir jetzt eben noch mal die Statistiken angeschaut. Wenn man rein auf die Höchstgeschwindigkeitswerte schaut, auf den Statistikseiten, dann ist gerade mal ein Fortuna-Spieler unter den Top 80 in der ganzen Liga, irgendwo auf Platz 50 ungefähr. Das ist Jona Niemetz. Von dem hat bestimmt noch nicht so alt so viele gehört. Der wurde nämlich im Winter genau aus dem Grund, weil man einfach noch einen schnellen Spieler brauchte, aus der zweiten Mannschaft hochgezogen. Das zeigt, glaube ich, schon recht deutlich, wie viele Fehler da auch im Sommer wieder gemacht worden sind. Und das hat leider nicht zum ersten Mal.
Worin glaubst du, liegt das, dass man sich bei Transfers so ein bisschen schwer tut? Müssen wir da über die verantwortlichen Personen sprechen? Sind es wirtschaftliche Gründe? Wo würdest du da ansetzen?
Ja, es ist natürlich eine Mischung aus beidem. Natürlich sind es irgendwo wirtschaftliche Gründe. Aber ich glaube, die meisten Vereine in der Liga beneiden Fortuna mit Sicherheit um die wirtschaftlichen Möglichkeiten, die man hat. Und ich glaube, da wird einfach sehr häufig nicht allzu clever agiert. Und das muss man einfach dem Sportvorstand Klaus Alofs anlassen, wie ich finde. Der ist jetzt seit zweieinhalb Jahren da und hat ehrlicherweise nicht allzu viel vorzuweisen, außer dass er sehr viel Geld ausgibt. Und gerade die Transfers, die quasi die Königstransfers sein sollen, da würde ich jetzt mal so als Beispiel den von Daniel Ginczek letztes Jahr heranführen, dass die eigentlich ab dem Augenblick schlecht sind, wo die Tinte trocknet. Also ich glaube, wenn man jemanden wie Daniel Ginczek holt, der Topverdiener im Verein ist, dann muss man eigentlich damit rechnen, dass der extrem verletzungsanfällig ist. Also ich glaube, das durchzieht seine Karriere einfach seit Jahren. Und genau das ist jetzt einfach in dieser Saison auch passiert. In der letzten Saison war der extrem wichtig. Da wurde auch direkt der ganze Spielstil der Mannschaft darauf ausgerichtet. Der hat sich dann am Anfang dieser Saison verletzt. Und da hat man relativ lange gebraucht, um das umzustellen, um nicht so abhängig von Daniel Ginczek zu sein, weil der einfach sehr, sehr viele Bälle vorne festgemacht hat. Und das ist eben nicht der einzige Transfer dieser Art.
Ich wollte nur einmal ganz kurz fragen, weil ich finde, ein Transfer von Düsseldorf hat durchaus eingeschlagen, auch wenn er vorher nicht so die Rolle gespielt hat mit Michael Karbovnik, weil ich würde schon sagen, dass er durchaus einen Impact hatte, auch wenn er nur clean ist. Oder würdest du jetzt sagen, das ist okay für eine Liar, aber du bräuchtest den jetzt auch nicht länger bei Düsseldorf sehen?
Ich tue mich unglaublich schwer, den zu bewerten, weil ich glaube, wenn man den Spielen sieht an einem guten Tag, also das ist ein relativ variabel einsetzbarer Spieler, bei Fatouna spielt er jetzt aber vor allen Dingen auf der linksverteidiger Position, ist er aber eigentlich jemand, der viel offensiver denkt. Ich glaube, wenn er halt einmal Tempo aufnimmt und defensiv nicht so gefordert wird, dann sieht er aus wie der beste Spieler der Liga. Oder wie einer der besten Spieler der Liga auf jeden Fall. Er hat unglaubliches Talent, kann super schwer gestoppt werden. Also da kann man auf jeden Fall sehen, was Alovs in ihm gesehen hat. Ein wirklich spektakulärer Spieler, aber gerade defensiv, finde ich, gefällt er mir einfach nicht. Er hat sehr oft an Gegentoren beteiligt und hat einfach auch gar nicht die Körperlichkeit für diese Position. Und man sieht auch relativ gut, warum es in der 2. Englischen Liga, wo er, glaube ich, hergeliehen ist, warum es da eben nicht gereicht hat. Also da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, wo es für ihn hingeht. Weil der Votuna hat, glaube ich, sogar eine Kaufoption, aber die ist, glaube ich, so hoch, dass die auch nicht gezogen werden kann. Aber das ist eben auch genau einer der Gründe. Also genau, weil sich Alovs oft in der Bundesliga umschaut oder in England und sehr, sehr selten mal in der 2. Liga einfach mal auf verlässliche Spieler geht. Ja, glaube ich, hat die Mannschaft oft so Probleme, weil ja, solche Spieler kann man eben dann oft erst sehr spät verpflichten. Da ist dann meistens schon ein Drittel der Saison um, wenn die wirklich vernünftig eingebaut werden können. Und das war jetzt bei Karbovnik nicht anders. Der ist, glaube ich, auch erst in den letzten Augusttagen gekommen. Und ja, man kann halt eben auch andere Spieler holen. Die haben dann vielleicht nicht dieses absolute Top-End-Talent, aber wissen halt genau, wie es in der 2. Liga läuft. Die kannst du direkt mit ins Trainingslager nehmen. Die kannst du in den ersten Spielen sofort einbauen und kannst einfach ein bisschen mehr auf Kontinuität setzen.
Ganz kurze Anschlussfrage noch. Dann die Frage noch Kownazki, weil der geht ja im Sommer. Der hat jetzt ja auch erst richtig durchgeschlagen, war ja auch viel ausgeliehen. Würdest du da auch so Alous ein bisschen angreiden, dass man jetzt schon das Gefühl hat, er spielt für einen neuen Vertrag in einer höheren Liga. Dass von Alous vielleicht auch einfach so ein bisschen die Perspektive gefehlt hat, dass er vielleicht mit Düsseldorf aufsteigen könnte. Oder denkst du, das liegt dann eher am Spieler?
Nee, also da würde ich Alous komplett rausnehmen. Dass David Kumajatsky jetzt in dieser Saison auf einmal, nachdem er schon seit über drei Jahren hier ist, auf einmal genau dieser Spieler geworden ist, weswegen Vertwung er damals so viel Geld für ihn gezahlt hat. Das ist mit großem Abstand der teuerste Transfer in der Geschichte des Vereins. Damit konnte niemand wirklich rechnen. Ich glaube, dem wurde vor der Saison gesagt, dass er sich gerne einen neuen Verein suchen kann. Ich glaube, nur Daniel Thun hat ihn dann letztendlich davon überzeugt, dass er das jetzt hier nochmal einfach versuchen soll. Das hat einfach vom ersten Spieltag an so gut funktioniert, dass man es eigentlich kaum fassen konnte. Der wird mit großem Recht jetzt wahrscheinlich in die Bundesliga wechseln oder vielleicht auch in eine andere Liga. Aber ich glaube, da war es nicht möglich, dem eine Perspektive aufzuzeigen, weil einfach ab dem Moment, wo es funktioniert hat, war einfach völlig offensichtlich, dass er halt einfach zu gut für die 2. Liga ist. Ich glaube, wenn man von Anfang an auf Platz 1, Platz 2 gestanden hätte, hätte man vielleicht nochmal drüber reden können oder würde auch jetzt nochmal drüber reden können, ob man nicht einfach dann zusammen diesen Schritt in die Bundesliga gehen will. Aber weil das einfach nicht der Fall ist, glaube ich, ist da im Endüsseldorf letztendlich auch Kungatzki keiner Böse, dass er sich einfach dann nächstes Jahr woanders sieht.
Mit 8 Vorlagen und 12 Toren. Jeweils bester Vorlagengeber und bester Torschütze im Team. Wenn du jetzt jemanden beschreiben müsstest, der in dieser Saison gar kein Spiel der Fortuna gesehen hat, was wir natürlich hart verurteilen. Aber was würde man denn dann sehen, außer ein 4-4-2 mit Doppel-6, jetzt in den letzten Spielen?
Es ist eine starke Ausrichtung am Gegner. Es gibt jetzt, glaube ich, nicht den einen Daniel-Tun-Fußball, so wie es jetzt zum Beispiel in Hamburg ist, wo man eigentlich genau weiß, was man bekommt. Sondern das ist schon immer relativ variabel. Was aber ein ganz, ganz wichtiges Stilmittel ist, ist, dass eigentlich der Torwart vielleicht der wichtigste Mann für die Spielauslösung ist. Das ist Florian Kastenmaier. Der wurde auch relativ viel kritisiert in den Jahren, die er jetzt schon hier ist, weil er sehr riskant spielt. Er ist aber eben auch einer der, vielleicht einer von den 1, 2, 3 besten Torhütern mit dem Ball am Fuß ist in der Liga. Er hat sich dann noch mal weiterentwickelt und das nutzt Thioune sehr stark. Der wird in den Aufbau eingebunden. Man lockt dann meistens die Gegner so ein bisschen raus. Dann spielt er wirklich absolut zielgenaue Bälle zur Mittellinie. Da sollen dann entweder Ginczek, wenn er fit ist, oder David Kupnacki, die die Kopfballduelle gewinnen oder die Bälle festmachen. Dann würde es eigentlich relativ gut tun, wenn man den Ball auf schneller Außen legen könnte. Das geht leider nicht. Aber man hat trotzdem den einen oder anderen Spieler, die einen relativ guten Ball in die Spitze spielen können. Das ist jetzt ein Schinter-Appel-Kampf, ob das ein Out-Hanaka ist. Letztendlich hängt dann auch sehr viel daran, was David Kupnacki macht. Weil er sich teilweise auch ins Mittelfeld zurückfallen lässt, fast wie so eine Art zweiter Spielmacher agiert. Man versucht dann vielleicht, wenn es geht, auch noch den schon angesprochenen Karbovnik in Eins-gegen-eins-Duelle zu bekommen. Aber er richtet das wie gesagt einfach sehr häufig am Gegner aus, wie hoch man steht, wie tief man steht, ob man mehr über Ballbesitz kommen will über Positionsspiel oder auch mal nicht.
Und das ganze Jahr sehr erfolgreich. Genau die Hälfte aller Spiele hat man stand jetzt gewinnen können. 5 unentschieden, 9 Niederlagen noch mit dazu. Man hat die drittbeste Abwehr der Liga und die fünftbeste Defensive. Wenn ich mich gerade nicht erzählt habe, da könnte auch die sechstbeste Defensive sein. Aber eben, das ist die Bilanz eines eventuellen Aufsteigers. Das ist noch nicht total Spitze, aber das ist eben auch sehr, sehr gut. Wir haben es vorhin schon zum Einstieg gehabt, deswegen will ich dich jetzt auch zum Ausstieg aus dem Segment noch mal fragen, wie groß ist denn die konkrete Hoffnung, dass es jetzt noch umgeht? Und gibt es vielleicht sogar auch eine Notwendigkeit, weil das Fortuna Düsseldorf von den Strukturen her gerne in der ersten Liga auch gesehen ist. Das haben wir ja zum Teil auch schon beobachten dürfen. Wie blickst du jetzt auf einen möglichen Ausgang dieser Saison im Aufstiegsfall und im Nicht-Aufstiegsfall?
Ja, also die absolute Notwendigkeit ist glaube ich nicht da. Aber man merkt schon, dass anscheinend jetzt auch in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren finanziell ein relativ großes Risiko gegangen wurde bei den Transfers. Mehr als man sich vielleicht irgendwie erst eingestehen wollte. Und das würde natürlich, so wie so wie jedem Verein, aber auch besonders der Fortuna schon schon sehr, sehr gut tun. Weil ich glaube, jetzt die nächsten beiden Jahre fallen die beiden Bundesligasaisons aus der TV-Geldtabelle. Da wird man dann irgendwann anfangen müssen kleinere Brötchen zu backen. Und von der Hoffnung her, also ich habe ja schon gesagt, dass meine Hoffnung eigentlich ehrlich gesagt nicht so wirklich groß war. Jetzt hat man natürlich diese dankbare Aufgabe, auf diese schöne Hamburger Stadt derby am Freitag gucken zu können. Und sich dann eigentlich – ist mir völlig egal, wie es ausgeht – so ein bisschen einreden zu können, dass das da eigentlich ein ganz gutes Ergebnis ist. Also ich glaube, ein Unentschieden wäre mir eigentlich fast am liebsten, muss ich sagen. Dann könnte man sowohl dieses berühmte HSV-Narrativ weiterspinnen, als auch, ja, hätte irgendwie das Gefühl, dass St. Pauli ein bisschen weiter eingebremst ist. Ich glaube, wenn das nicht passiert – ich würde ehrlich gesagt sogar wirklich sagen, wenn dieses Spiel nicht unentschieden ausgeht, ist gar keine Chance mehr für die Fußballer. Und ein Grund, warum ich da so pessimistisch bin, ist, dass im zentralen Mittelfeld eigentlich die beiden absoluten Leistungsträger ausfallen mit Autanaka und Jorrit Hendricks. Das heißt, dass man nur zwei Sechser auf der Position noch hat, die eher defensiv denken und wenig Struktur nach vorne geben. Gerade weil man jetzt im nächsten Spiel in Nürnberg und danach in den beiden Heimspielen, die danach kommen gegen Karlsruhe und Kiel, wahrscheinlich Mannschaften bespielen muss, vor allen Dingen jetzt glaube ich eben in Nürnberg, die sich wahrscheinlich hinten rein stellen werden. Da wird man da unbedingt Lösungen brauchen und ich weiß nicht wirklich, ob der Kader das wirklich hergeben wird.
Also, dann schauen wir, ob es ein Unentschieden wird erstmal und ab dann wissen wir ja schon, wie es weitergeht für Fortuna Düsseldorf. Ich glaube, Eva würde sich eine solche Gewissheit schon innerhalb von wenigen Tagen wahrscheinlich wünschen, denn Eva, egal wie lange wir warten damit, dass wir wieder miteinander sprechen, die Armenia kommt einfach nicht da unten raus. Wir machen jetzt einen riesigen Sprung von Rang 4, wo die Fortuna aktuell liegt, zu Rang 15. Die Armenia hat 29 Punkte. 2 Punkte Vorsprung ist es auf den Relegationsplatz. Warum konnte man sich, seitdem wir das letzte Mal gesprochen haben, nicht von da unten befreien? Gefühlt probiert die Armenia doch alles, was man so tun kann in solchen Situationen.
Gute Frage. Wahrscheinlich, weil man unter anderem die Duelle gegen zwei oder einen Großteil der direkten Konkurrenten einfach nicht gewinnen konnte. Ich glaube, man ist die einzige Mannschaft, die beide Spiele gegen Rostock und Sandhausen verloren hat. Und es war ja direkt zum Start der Hinrunde und der Rückrunde, dass man diese Spiele verloren hat. Gerade jetzt in der Rückrunde, wo ich ganz klar sage, muss einfach nicht, weil die Gegner jetzt auch nicht so viel mehr angeboten haben. Und gerade wenn man mal bei Rostock auf die Torausbeute guckt, in keiner Weise respektlos gemeint, aber wir waren lange Zeit der einzige Gegner, gegen den Rostock überhaupt in 2023 ein Tor erzielen konnte, ist das halt einfach super unnötig. Also man steht sich oft selbst im Weg. Ich glaube, dieses 4-2 am Wochenende gegen Karlsruhe war leider eine absolute, war sehr bildlich dafür. Also man hat ja vor dem 24. Spieltag den Trainer gewechselt. Also auch das war eine sehr ereignisreichere Woche. Man hatte am Sonntag das 3-3 gegen Braunschweig, nachdem man 3-0 führte und dann das Spiel noch außer Hand gegeben hat. Mit einem 3-3, was sich dann eher wieder in Niederlage angefühlt hat. Darauf wurden dann ja die Stimmen auch gegen Sami Haravi das erste Mal richtig laut. Der ist dann am Montag zurückgetreten, nachdem er über zehn Jahre bei der Arminia war. Grund dafür soll unter anderem auch gewesen sein, dass klar war, mit Daniel Scherning wird es so wahrscheinlich nicht weitergehen. Der war ja nach vier Spieltagen für Uli Vortege gekommen. Und wenn Daniel Scherning geht, wird Sami Haravi wahrscheinlich auch gehen müssen. Einfach weil seine beiden Trainer nicht funktioniert haben. Ich habe einfach mal grob überschlagen. Seit 2010, also das Jahr bevor Sami Haravi gekommen ist, hatte Arminia Bielfeld 20 Trainer. Unter anderem so schöne Namen wie Christian Ziege, Markus von Ahlen, unter anderem auch Ewald Lien. Es ist die zweite Dreitrennersaison von Sami Haravi. Letztes Mal 17, 18 mit Rem Kramny und Sabine. Da hat man den Klassenerhalt geschafft. Am letzten Spieltag, nachdem man vorletzten Spieltag 6-0 gegen Braunschweig gewonnen hat und dann am letzten Spieltag unentschieden gegen Dresden, gleichzeitig einen gegen 18, 60 gewonnen hat. Aber es war auch so, dass Sami Haravi kaum noch öffentlich präsent war. Ich glaube, ich habe das nicht erzählt, weil das haben wir davor aufgenommen. Ich war damals auf der Jahreshauptversammlung letztes Jahr. Jegliche Kritik, die an Sami Haravi aufkam, wurde vom Präsidenten von Rainer Schütte eher moderiert oder von Hartmut Ostrovski im Aussichtsrat fortsetzenden und von Haravi selber eigentlich gar nicht beantwortet. Weil eben auch die Frage nach der Trainerfluktuation aufkam. Dann wurde Uwe Koschinert geholt und nahm auch vom neuen Geschäftsführer Finanzen oder wie immer das Finanzgeschäftsführer, wie man das auch nennen will, Christoph Wortmann, der zum Januar die Nachfolge von Markus Reheck angetreten hat. Bielefeld war auch zwei Monate ohne Geschäftsführer im Bereich Finanzen. Das hat Samir Rabih dann auch in die Personalunion übernommen. Christoph Wortmann hat dann zusammen mit dem Präsidium und Aufsichtsrat sich für Uwe Koschin hat entschieden. Und da war er etwas skeptisch hier in Bielefeld. Weil es war klar, der dritte Trainer muss jetzt funktionieren. Koschin hat davor bei Saarbrücken, bei Sandhausen, vor Thuner Köln sehr lange gewesen. Ich habe hier lange mit Louis Löser geredet, der ihn als Sandhausen-Fan Uwe Koschin sehr gut kennt und ihn auch immer noch, glaube ich, wieder gerne zurück haben möchte. Der hat gesagt, mit dem schaffte er das mehr oder weniger. Man hat im ersten Spiel unter ihm gegen Darmstadt gewonnen 3 zu 1. Dann unentschieden gegen Nürnberg, sehr unglücklich. Ehrlich gesagt, auswärts in Kiel gewonnen, unentschieden gegen Düsseldorf, wo Bielefeld, glaube ich, auch noch nicht so ganz weiß, wie man da einen Punkt geholt hat. Mit kräftiger Mithilfe der Fortuna, glaube ich. Und jetzt halt leider das erste Spiel unter ihm in Karlsruhe verloren hat, wo ich ironischerweise sagen muss, das war mit das beste Spiel unter Koschin, das was ich gesehen habe. Man hatte aber 4 Latten-Treffer in 90 Minuten. Da ist Bielefeld Rekordhalter mit 14 Latten- und Pfosten-Treffer der Liga im Allgemeinen. Und man halt innerhalb von sieben Minuten dieses Spiel komplett aus der Hand gibt, durch drei individuelle Fehler eben im Endeffekt 4-2 verliert, anstatt wie selber Christian Eichner, unser Trainer von Karlsruhe, der meinte, eigentlich muss Bielefeld zur 60. Minute 5-1 führen und spiegelt 4-2 aus. Für Karlsruhe fasst, glaube ich, die Saison von Bielefeld ganz gut zusammen. Obwohl ich sagen muss, dass es trotzdem so ist, dass ich unter Koschina etwas mehr Hoffnung habe. Also wenn man mal auf die Saison zurückguckt, war ja Bielefeld mehr in den letzten Top-3 seit Koschina-Trainer. Da ist man konstant, zumindest über Platz 16. Aber ja, also generell kann man glaube ich sagen, es ist viel zu wenig für diesen Kader. Man sieht, unter Koschina hat das erste Mal, glaube ich, so richtig, was wir uns von diesem Kader alle erhofft haben. Und Rotkolev bin, so wenn man mit ihm vielleicht in die Saison gestartet wäre. Aber ja, also das ist so, das ist so 2023. Es ist super spaßig.
Ja, vor allem das eigentlich Bizarre ist ja, also Bielefeld hat ja gepunktet, also allein unter Koschina hat 8 der 29 Punkte geholt und trotzdem Rang 15, 2 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz. Kommt es mir nur so vor oder ist es in diesem Jahr besonders, dass eben da unten immer mal wieder jemand punktet und es eigentlich fast kein Team gibt, vielleicht über eins werden wir vielleicht gleich noch reden müssen, was so richtig abreißen lässt?
Ja, also was ganz wichtig ist in der 2. Liga, ist, dass du halt Serien startest. Also ich meine, klar, São Paulo ist da der Verein, der da am meisten heraussticht. Aber generell, also gibt es super viele Vereine, die zeigen, was negativ und positiv Serien ausmachen können. Hannover bestimmt ein Negativbeispiel. Das bringt nichts, wenn du nur ein Spiel gewinnst, wie gegen in einer Reihe von nicht gewonnenen Spielen in 2023. Das einzige Spiel, das du gewinnst, ist Sandhausen. Gut, damit hast du vielleicht den Klassenerhalt geschafft. Aber in dieser Gesamtkonstellation, ich meine, da habt ihr ja auch im letzten Kurzpass drüber geredet, das ist schon in dieser Rückrunde einfach viel zu wenig. Und das ist halt ein ganz, ganz großes Ding. Also dir hilft ein Ergebnis überhaupt nicht weiter. Also du, ironischerweise hätte Bielefeld gewonnen. Und je nachdem, was Regensburg gemacht hätte und wir gewonnen hätten, kann man so ein bisschen sagen, ja, okay, vielleicht wäre das fast schon so ein bisschen der frühzeitige Klassenerhalt gewesen mit vorsichtigen Blick, weil das ist immer noch die zweite Liga. Und was ja lustigerweise, ich glaube, Bielefeld hat jetzt schon fast so viele Tore geschossen wie in den letzten beiden Bundesligasaisons zusammen, also ein bisschen weniger. Ich glaube, da waren es ja irgendwie so 53-54 dann zusammen gerechnet, 43. Bielefeld hat genauso viele Tore geschossen wie Darmstadt mit 43. Daran liegt es gar nicht mal. Wir haben genug Torschützen irgendwie. Also Fabian Kloss ist irgendwie erlebt sein, weiß ich nicht, achten Frühling. Brian Lassme schießt auf einmal Tore. Robin Huck, Masaya Okugawa ist irgendwie zurück. Dann macht einen Mittelfeldspieler, von dem wir alle dachten, okay, das ist auch ein Flop gewesen. Haut irgendwie so das Ding in den Winkel gegen Darmstadt. Also irgendwie die Tore schießen, das ist gar nicht mal per se das Problem. Aber du hast halt auch die zweitschlechteste Defensive zusammen mit Magdeburg nach Sandhausen mit 49 Gegentoren. Und das war halt gerade durch individuelle Fehler. Das Problem ist halt auch einfach, dass du keine Konstanz in die Abwehr bekommst. Also es gibt zwei Spieler, die gerade in der Innenverteidigung, die für viele Bielefeld-Fans, glaube ich, gesetzt sind. Das sind Giliam Ramosch und Andres Andrade. Konnten jetzt zuletzt im Spiel gegen Karlsruhe eben nicht spielen. Oli Hüsing, der vor der Saison als der Stabilisator kommen sollte, funktioniert leider einfach nicht so. Ich glaube, da ganz viel verbrannte Erde in den ersten Spielen. Er ist einer der Spieler, wo wir gehofft haben, gut, wenn jemand wie Pritle es schafft, wenn Klose es schafft, wieder zur alter Form zurückzufinden. Auch Vasejades vielleicht, Kanzen Hüsing vielleicht auch. Das Karlsruhespiel hat sich nicht dazu geeignet, das zu beweisen, weil er einfach unfassbar unglücklich war und für mindestens zwei Gegentore verantwortlich ist. Das muss man leider einfach so sagen. Alleine unter Koschinat in den fünf Spielen hattest du vier verschiedene Innenverteidigungen. Du hattest nur zweimal untereinander die gleiche Viererkette hinten. Das war in einem Darmstadt- und Nürnbergspiel mit Oczipka, Andrade, Ramosch, Gehbauer. Obwohl auch Gehbauer schon der Ersatz für Klünter war. Weil Gehbauer eigentlich kein gelernter Rechtsverteidiger ist. Dafür ist er zu schlecht ein Rechtsverteidiger. Dann hattest du Oczipka, Jäkel, Ramosch, Klünter. Dann hattest du Ramosch, Andrade, Jäkel. Und dann hattest du Oczipka, Hüsing, Jäkel, Klünter. Davon abgesehen, dass es immer wieder ein Wechsel von Dreier- zu Viererkette gab. Du hast unterschiedliche Außen, du hast die unterschiedlichen Innenverteidiger. Du hast mit Jäkel und Hüsing also weiter auseinander geht es kaum. Ich glaube, das ist der jüngste Innenverteidiger und der älteste Innenverteidiger, den wir haben. Und du bekommst einfach keine Stabilität da hinten rein. Das siehst du dann in solchen Spielen, dass einfach die Abstimmung nicht passt, als wenn da ein Ramosch und ein Andrade stehen, die dir halt einfach alles stumpf wegverteidigen. In Ramosch-Fällen vielleicht auch ein oder andere Mal ein bisschen drüber, obwohl man ironischerweise sagen muss, dass die fünfte gelbe Karte ausnahmsweise mal keine gelbe Karte war. Sonst verdient er die sich immer redlich. Aber da kommt halt irgendwie alles zusammen. Und das ist halt was, was Koshinat jetzt auch stark kritisiert hat, was Fabian Kloh stark kritisiert hat, der gesagt hat, so können wir nicht verteidigen wie in Karlsruhe. So schaffen wir den Klassener halt nicht. Koshinat hat auch gesagt, wir können nicht immer 5 oder 6 Tore schießen in einem Spiel. Nur, damit wir am Ende das Spiel gewinnen. Das beschreibt das Problem halt ganz gut. Und es ist halt ein bisschen wenig Zeit, um da jetzt zu sagen, okay, da haben wir jetzt irgendwie Zeit, uns einzufinden. Sondern du musst dich jetzt halt, ja, wahrscheinlich hoffen, dass Andrade und Ramosch ehrlich gesagt den Rest der Saison so dann zusammen spielen können, ohne dass es irgendwie nochmal Verletzungen gibt etc. Und dann gucken, dass du einfach jetzt in den folgenden Spielen so wenig wie möglich Gegentore kassierst.
Was eine Herausforderung ist bei einem Gegentore-Schnitt von 1, 8 pro Spiel. Und wir haben einen hier in der Runde, der durfte erst am vorletzten Spieltag war es dann, mit angucken, wie man zwei Tore erzielt, aber auch zwei kassiert. Fortuna Düsseldorf hat ja unter anderem auf der Alm gespielt. Da hat Fabian Kloss das 1 zu 0 gemacht. Und dann gab es aber da den Doppelschlag. Und erst hinten raus musste man dann eigentlich fast froh sein, noch einen Punkt mitzunehmen. Lukas, wie hat dir denn das gefallen, was du da bei Bielefeld gesehen hast, mal ausgehend davon, dass ja Fortuna Düsseldorf sicherlich jetzt nicht zufrieden war, da nur unentschieden gespielt zu haben?
Mir hat eigentlich trotzdem ganz gut gefallen, was ich da gesehen habe. Also Düsseldorf hatte an dem Tag, glaube ich, wirklich einen guten Tag. Sondern das Out-Tana, den haben sie gar nicht in den Griff bekommen, aber das, was man sich da überlegt hatte, dass man da auf Dreierkette umgestellt hat, das war eigentlich relativ clever und hat, glaube ich, Thun auch relativ kalt erwischt. Auch wenn die Fortuna da doch eigentlich dann relativ gut mit fertig geworden ist, dann im Laufe des Spiels war das aber auf jeden Fall erstmal genau der Kniff, glaube ich, den es gebraucht hat, um der Fortuna zu begegnen. Deswegen ist man dann irgendwie auch in Führung gegangen, hat viele lange Bälle auf Sarah und auf Klos vorne geschlagen und das hat der Fortuna auf jeden Fall ziemlich die Probleme bereitet. Also, wie gesagt, die Fortuna war dann trotzdem ganz ordentlich im Spiel, hat dann aber eben die Tore, auch wenn es Chancen vorher schon gab, erst gemacht, als es dann wieder zu einer Verletzung kam bei den Wiedefellern. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht mehr, wer es gewesen ist, auf jeden Fall musste dann in der Pause von Dreierkette auf Viererkette umgestellt werden. Dann macht die Fortuna die Tore und sah wirklich wie der sichere Sieger aus. Dann hat sich leider Aotanaka verletzt und wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr spielen in dieser Saison. Und ja, es fehlte dann an diesem Tag ein physischer Sechser eigentlich. Tune hat sich dann dafür entschieden, glaube ich, Appelkampf da aufzustellen. Und das haben die Wiedefeller eiskalt ausgenutzt. Haben dann das Zentrum kontrolliert. Haben die Düsseldorfer hinten eingeschnürt. Und ja, da konnte Fatouna eigentlich wirklich gar nicht mehr richtig mit umgehen. Und das 2.2 war dann letztendlich doch eigentlich folgerichtig. Und ja, das war jetzt natürlich auch nur so ein Spiel. Aber ehrlich gesagt hat mich das auch ziemlich optimistisch gestimmt aus Sicht der Wiedefeller. Also ich glaube ehrlich gesagt auch, dass Koschin hat da genau der richtige Mann ist. Und ja, dass man da einfach am Ende die nötigen Punkte dann noch holen wird. Und ja, das hat man auch in dem Spiel gesehen, dass das eigentlich genau der richtige Trainer ist gerade.
Deckt sich das denn mit deinem Gefühl, Eva? Also das muss ja runtergehen wie Öl, das so zu hören. Gleichzeitig sehen wir ja trotz all der Punkte, die man gesammelt hat, ist es ja noch ein Stück weit zu gehen. Und man kann sich zwar immer sicher darüber sein, dass es viele Zuschauer vor Ort geben wird, die zugucken, was eh schon erstaunlich ist. Also gibt es da irgendeine Euphorie bei Bielefeld, die immer so auch dann schon da war als Schaning oder Rabi noch da war. Also es ist ja ein bisschen auffällig.
Ja, es ist halt tatsächlich ein bisschen lustig. Also es ist glaube ich inzwischen wie so ein Running-Gag lustigerweise. Im Spiel gegen der Amstrand waren es 18.000. Das war mit, ich glaube, gegen Heidenheim war es Liga, also der schlechteste Zuschauer in dem Schnitt mit glaube ich so 17.000. Und dann, also ich meine, dann hat man ein Spiel gegen Darmstadt gewonnen und dann waren 13.473 Zuschauer im Spiel gegen Nürnberg da. Und ich meine, man war immer noch so Platz 15. Und ist man jetzt wieder dann gegen Düsseldorf auch über 23.000. Wenn es jetzt für das Spiel ging, Hannover, sind schon wieder über 23.500 Karten verkauft. Also Bielefeld ist auf einem Weg zu einem zuschauenden Rekord in der 2. Liga, also zu einem Vereinsrekord in dieser Saison. Es ist halt immer so ein bisschen ironisch. Nee, es ist also viele, natürlich hat das auch damit zu tun, weil die Saison, wo man es ja wahrscheinlich eigentlich geknackt hätte, das war halt die Ausstiegssaison. Aber da fallen halt die Hälfte der Spiele weg ohne Fans. Das ist natürlich immer noch was, wo viele auch sagen, boah, was wäre möglich gewesen. Man muss ja trotzdem sagen, es ist halt sowieso die Sorte von Fans, die da am Samstag zusammenkommen, Hannover-Fans und Millefeld-Fans, die leiden auf jeden Fall gerne. Anders kann ich mir das nicht mehr erklären. Ich glaube, das ist halt, es klingt jetzt ein bisschen kipptisch, aber es gibt ein Aminia-Lied, da geht die Zeile, glaube ich, auch wenn wir wissen, dass wir Besseres verdienen, bleiben wir stets zusammen, bleiben wir stets am Minen. Also irgendwie dieses, naja, okay, Leute, wir haben hier jetzt irgendwie noch nie lange Bundesliga gespielt, so nach dem Motto. Und der Kader, der jetzt gerade ist, also zwischendurch stehen hier immer noch viele Väter, okay, man kann so Fußball spielen, okay, krass, so, wusste ich nicht. Ich glaube einfach, dass im Endeffekt hier sehr viele meckerte Menschen sitzen, aber gleichzeitig auch immer Leute, die man sehr schnell begeistern kann. Und wenn man den zeigt, und das ist einfach so unter Uwe Koschinath, wird einfach das erste Mal vernünftig Fußball gespielt in dieser Saison. Es wird mit einem Konzept Fußball gespielt. Natürlich ist es immer so, das ist seit 11 Jahren, oder sagen wir 8 Jahren bei Aminia Bielefeld so, wenn du Fabian Kloss irgendwie in dein Boot bekommst und dem dann gleichzeitig, ich meine, Uwe Koschinath, der konnte es besser nicht erwischen. Kloss, Jubiläumspiel, Rekordspiel für Aminia. Er schießt da ein Tor, überholt dann, also er bricht den Rekord im zweiten Spiel, schießt da auch ein Tor. Also besser kann es dann für dich auch nicht laufen. Er ist halt gesetzt. Gleichzeitig halt Leute wie Pridl, wo alle im Winter gesagt haben, oh Gott, ja bitte geh endlich so nach dem Motto. Warum hat er noch ein Vertrag bis 2024, der jetzt einfach komplett wieder aufblüht? Das habe ich eben schon mal angesprochen. So das sind so kleine Kniffe. Und was bei ihm tatsächlich ist, die Kommunikation. Also es gibt ein paar Sprüche, da muss ich ganz klar sagen, kann er sich sparen. Also ich weiß bis heute nicht, was Sätze bedeuten sollen, wie ja, wir sind männlich aus der Kabine gekommen. Ich weiß nicht, wie man männlich aus einer Kabine kommt, aber gut. Aber es ist halt, also ich gucke mir das erste Mal wieder freiwillig Pressekonferenzen von der Minia an, weil ich weiß, da wird jemand was sagen, das kann ich mitnehmen und das sehe ich am Wochenende auch auf dem Feld. Oder das habe ich auch auf dem Feld gesehen, sehr klare Analysen. Das war unter Scherning nicht so. Das war unter Vorte nicht so. Das war unter Frank Kramer nicht so. Ich möchte Kostmann da jetzt explizit ausklammern, weil er ist halt eigentlich Torwarttrainer und nicht normaler Trainer, sage ich jetzt mal. Selbst mit Abzügen war das auch unter Uwe Neuhaus nicht so. Also da haben Pressekonferenzen gefühlt drei Minuten gedauert, weil alle wussten, er wird dir sowieso nichts darüber erzählen, was passiert. Und ich glaube, das ist es. Also das ist vom Mensch her, man muss immer ein bisschen gucken, dass man es nicht verkultet, aber passt er halt gerade schon zu Bielefeld, weil man irgendwie schon das Gefühl hat, der hat Bielefeld sehr, sehr schnell verstanden in dem Sinne. Womit muss ich die Leute packen? Und das belohnen die Leute dann relativ schnell. Die sagen dann, okay, wir gehen jetzt hier in Vorleistung, wir kommen jetzt mit über 23.000 hier hin, aber dann zeigt uns halt auch, dass das funktioniert. Und das müssen sie jetzt halt gegen Hannover am Wochenende zeigen. Du spielst jetzt nur noch gegen Teams oberhalb von dir, was ich per se gar nicht so schlecht finde, weil Karlsruhe ist halt in diesem Mittelfeld-Ding. Aber du spielst jetzt halt gegen Hannover, okay. Dann spielst du gegen St. Pauli, gegen Fürth, gegen Kaiserslautern, glaube ich, gegen Paderborn und gegen Magdeburg, wenn ich es jetzt richtig draufhabe. Und alle eher weiter oben. Und ich sage mal, zu dem Zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich für Vereine wie Fürth, Lautern, wahrscheinlich auch Paderborn, sage ich jetzt mal so, für die es um nichts mehr geht. Je nachdem, wie Magdeburg sich anstellt, hoffen wir natürlich, dass es für sie schon durchaus noch um was geht, weil man ist halt auch nur drei Punkte voneinander entfernt. Aber dass man da vielleicht so ein bisschen schauen kann, okay, wir sind dann die Mannschaft, die hier noch um was spielt. Es kann immer gefährlich werden, gleichzeitig aber auch helfen, dass man halt sagt, okay, die gehen jetzt vielleicht nicht bis 90 plus volles Risiko. Von daher, ja, also ich finde es gar nicht so schlecht, dass wir jetzt mehr gegen Teams, die aus dem Abstiegskampf per se erstmal raus sind, spielen, weil, wie gesagt, man hat nur gegen Regensburg gewonnen, aus diesen, also Nürnberg nur unentschieden, Rostock und Sandhausen beides verloren, dass das vielleicht einem dann etwas näher liegt. Gleichzeitig wäre es schon wichtig, auch irgendwann zu wissen, wer Nachführer von Sami Yarabi wird, weil es gibt meiner Meinung nach eine ganz, ganz wichtige Personalie, und das ist Jomain Kuhnsbruch, ist ja Bielefelder. Und ja, da ist halt die Frage, kann man den halten? Ich würde es mir sehr wünschen, weil ich glaube, dass es einfach so jemand ist, der kann immer anders Euphorie entfachen. Also man hat jetzt ja auch gerade gesehen, dass die U17 von Bielefeld sehr überraschend deutscher Meister geworden ist. Und da man aber auch direkt sieht, Nick Czerny, so der beste Spieler aus dem Kader, hat schon vor einem halben Jahr Vertrag bei Borussia Dortmund unterschrieben. Aber auch da, um halt, ist halt auch schon wichtig, da einen Geschäftsführer Sport zu haben. Natürlich tut der das nicht nur, sondern in Kombination dann mit dem NLZ. Aber da auch den jungen Spielern halt irgendwie eine Perspektive aufzuzeigen, weil Uwe Neuers wurde ja damals offiziell auch entlassen, weil man einen Ausbildungsverein aufbauen wollte. Das hängt bei ganz, ganz vielen Bielefeld-Fans eben noch nach. Und wenn man gleichzeitig sieht, Leute wie Kloss und Pritl verdrängen einen Lipiniza, der zwar auch nur zur Laie hier ist, aber der halt jung ist, einen Serra, der auch noch relativ jung ist. Also ich meine, der Durchschnittsalter von Bielefeld ist 26, 4. Jetzt im Spiel gegen KSC war es bei ungefähr 28, 5. Oh Gott, 38. Himmelherrgott. Gleichzeitig sind Leute wie Robin Hug und Masaya Okogawa, die mit den meisten einsetzen. Die waren halb im Winter auch schon weg. Es gibt relativ viele Spieler, wo du jetzt auch langsam mal wissen musst, gab es da schon Gespräche noch unter Arabi? Wer könnte die Nachfolge sein? Das ist halt alles so ein bisschen was, was in der Schwebe hängt. Und ich glaube, je schneller Biele fällt im Zweifel, so ein bisschen klarmachen könnte, okay, in welcher Liga spielen wir nächste Saison? Natürlich am liebsten in der zweiten, logischerweise. Desto schneller ist das halt eben auch einfach ein Ding, wo man eine Zukunft anzeigen kann.
Wir werden das uns genau anschauen. Die ersten Spiele, du hast es ja schon erwähnt, oder Koscinat, die geben ja Anlass zur Hoffnung, auch wenn die Schwäche gegen die direkte Konkurrenz eben ein Problem für Bielefeld ist. Und da wissen wir, dass Olli sich natürlich an diesen Sieg sehr, sehr genau erinnert. Seiner Rostocker, oder seiner in Anführungszeichen natürlich. Aber du fühlst dich eben verbunden, so ist es richtig, Olli, in Bielefeld. Aber das hat auch einen traurigen Grund, nämlich, das war – festhalten, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer – der einzige Sieg in der Rückrunde von Hansa Rostock. Ansonsten hat man noch einen Unentschieden erzielt und ansonsten nur verloren. Also vier Punkte gesammelt, auch deshalb ist man auf den vorletzten Tabellenplatz abgerutscht. Und Olli, auch deshalb gab es ja auch bei Rostock einen Trainerwechsel.
Ja, den zweiten mittlerweile, genau zum Thema verbunden mit dem FC Hansa. Möchte ich an dieser Stelle auch sagen, dass ich ein Fan und auch Mitglied beim FC Hansa bin. Nicht wie, wenn wir sonst zusammensitzen, wenn wir über Magdeburg reden, wo ich ja die journalistisch begleite. Insofern weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber kann sein, dass das mich an der einen oder anderen Stelle einholt bei der einen oder anderen Formulierung. Genau, und als wir das letzte Mal zusammensaßen, bzw. zu dem Sieg, können wir noch sagen, das war mein Geburtstag, ich war im Stadion, also perfektes Geburtstagsgeschenk.
Ich wollte gerade schon sagen, man hat dann das nächste Mal Geburtstag, aber das weiß ich ja eigentlich. Das wäre ein bisschen spät, wenn er da das nächste Mal gewinnt.
Du bist also schuld.
Ja, das nehme ich gerne auf mich, aber ich hatte gehofft, dass vielleicht auch noch der eine oder andere Hansa-Fan irgendwann mal am Spieltag Geburtstag hat und dann auch ein ähnliches Geschenk bekommt. Hat leider nicht geklappt. Ja, und als wir das letzte Mal zusammensaßen – Max weiß gar nicht mehr, wie lange das her ist, so fünf Wochen wahrscheinlich ungefähr – da hatte ich ja auch gesagt, Uwe Koschinert ist ein Macher und dem traue ich eigentlich zu, dass er Bielefeld unten rausführt. Dafür haben sie bis jetzt dann doch recht wenig Punkte geholt. Und ich hatte auch gesagt, Hansa hat mit zwei Toren vier Punkte geholt. Und ich hoffe, dass wir auf Platz 14 stehen damals, nicht weiter abrutschen, damit wir eben in der kommenden Saison mit einem Auswärtsspiel im DFB-Pokal starten, was gleichbedeutend mit einem wahrscheinlich relativ sicheren Klassenhalt wäre. Ja, ist jetzt nicht so gekommen, weil – ihr habt das mehrfach schon angesprochen – Hansa einfach keine Tore schießt. Oder jetzt sind wir mal wieder ein bisschen dazu übergegangen, aber zwei gegen Düsseldorf nützen dir nicht so sonderlich viel, wenn du fünf bekommst. Zwei gegen Holstein Kiel nützen dir auch nicht so sonderlich viel, wenn du drei bekommst. Ja, und so sind wir unten reingerutscht. Und mit jedem Spieltag wird der Abstand gefühlt ein kleines bisschen größer gefühlt, deshalb weil die anderen – ihr habt das jetzt schon relativ ausführlich besprochen – ja auch nicht so richtig von der Stelle kommen an manchen Standorten. Ja, und deswegen gab es dann eben auch vor ein paar Wochen nochmal den zweiten Trainerwechsel diese Saison. Der erste war von Jens Härtel zu Patrick Glöckner, der zweite war jetzt zu Alois Schwarz. Aber die Ergebnisse lassen weiter auf sich warten leider.
Wobei man den Vorteil hat, dass man von allen Teams, die da unten drin stehen, also nur Eintracht Braunschweig hat so ein halbwegs vergleichbares Programm, man spielt noch gegen sehr viele direkte Konkurrenten. Also ich weiß nicht, ob man 4. jetzt schon dazuzählen darf, würde vielleicht jemand protestieren, auch lautern definitiv nicht. Aber dann geht's los. Anfang Mai Heimspiel gegen Jan Regensburg, aktuell Tabellenplatz 16. Dann Auswärtsspiel in Sandhausen, aktuell Tabellenplatz 18. Dann Auswärtsspiel beim 1. FC Nürnberg, aktuell Platz 14. Und am Ende der Saison ein Heimspiel zu Hause gegen genau jene Braunschweiger. Also es sind zwar nicht mehr viele Spiele, aber immerhin hat Schwarz die Möglichkeit, das vielleicht in diesen direkten Duellen zu richten.
Naja, das ist natürlich so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, an die man sich klammert. Aber meine Einschätzung ist da, wenn man jetzt ja mit dieser Serie, mit so vielen nicht gewonnenen oder verlorenen Spielen in diese vier Spiele geht, dann wird man die auch nicht gewinnen. So, also außer gegen Jan Regensburg vielleicht, weil gegen die gewinnen wir immer. Aber das würde ja jetzt nicht reichen, am Ende wahrscheinlich nicht mal reichen, um den Relegationsplatz zu bekommen. Gegen Sandhausen haben wir uns jetzt die meiste Zeit schwergetan in den Spielen in der 2. Bundesliga. Also ja, da würde ich mich jetzt nicht drauf verlassen. Aber so richtig, einen richtigen Hoffnungsschimmer, wie wir vorher schon in den Flow kommen, habe ich aktuell auch nicht, ehrlicherweise.
Okay, da musst du mir jetzt aber nochmal erklären. Olli, was ist denn da eigentlich passiert? Also die Hinrunde Hansa Rostock auf Tabellenplatz 9. Auch da hat man schon wenige Tore erzielt, aber das wussten alle. 17 Tore erzielt, 23 kassiert. Daraus hat man 21 Punkte gemacht. Also man hat es immerhin geschafft, eben da mit wenig viel zu erreichen. Und jetzt dann eben die angesprochenen 4 Punkte, die man bisher gesammelt hat. Und deswegen steht man jetzt bei 25 und auf dem vorletzten Tabellenplatz. Wie ist das zu erklären?
Ich glaube, das ist eine Reihe von Gründen, die da irgendwie eine Rolle spielen. Dann müssen wir auch nochmal einen Schritt zurückgehen in die letzte Saison. Das war ja dann unser erstes Jahr in der 2. Bundesliga nach sehr vielen Jahren. Neun Jahren dritte Liga, glaube ich. Und ja, dann ist man zur Halbserie, stand man, glaube ich, knapp über dem Strich. Hatte auch bedingt durch gute Pokalspiele so eine gewisse Euphorie, die dann einige Punkte geholt haben. War dann aber vor Weihnachten so ein bisschen in so ein Trott geraten, dass man dann nicht mehr so richtig gewonnen hat. Und dann ging man ins Jahr 2022. Und ja, dann hat es irgendwie auch noch ein bisschen gedauert. Und dann haben wir Mitte Februar, also auch wieder kurz vor meinem Geburtstag, haben wir 4 zu 1 bei Dynamo Dresden gewonnen. So, und das war, glaube ich, so ein bisschen der Startpunkt. Dann gab es noch einen Unentschieden gegen Darmstadt, Niederlage, gegen Nürnberg. Und dann kam die Serie, über die wir heute in Rostock, glaube ich, immer noch alle sprechen. Da gab es einen 4 zu 3-Sieg auf Schalke und danach folgend drei Siege gegen Kiel, gegen Sandhausen und zu Hause gegen St. Pauli. Damals noch Tabellenführer, das war natürlich in Rostock dann eine relativ große Freude, diesen zu stürzen und dann auch nicht mehr auf die Beine kommen zu sehen für den Rest der Saison, während man selbst sich mit diesem Spiel faktisch gerettet hatte. Ja, und dann gab es Diskussionen um den Trainer Jens Herthel, die ich aus der Ferne nur so bedingt nachvollziehen könnte. Also bei Jens Herthel ist es üblich, dass er seine Verträge immer nur um ein Jahr verlängert. Insofern hat man dann relativ regelmäßig die Diskussion, ob wieder verlängert werden sollte und das hat sich dann irgendwie hingezogen. Das haben alle nicht verstanden, weil Jens Herthel war der Trainer nach der Wende, der Hansa am längsten betreut hat. Frank Pagelsdorf war zweimal da. Der ist insgesamt länger da gewesen, aber am Stück war Jens Herthel am längsten da. Er hat uns mit kontinuierlicher Arbeit aus der dritten Liga rausgebracht, hat uns souverän in der zweiten Liga gehalten. Dann gab es ein paar Aussagen vom Sportdirektor Martin Piekenhagen, die mich darauf schließen lassen, dass man so ein bisschen mehr wollte. Dass er so etwas gesagt hat wie, wir wollen uns natürlich in der zweiten Bundesliga etablieren, wir wollen aber auch spielerisch vorankommen. Da müssen wir eben gucken, ob das der richtige Trainer ist oder welchen Trainer wir dafür brauchen. So sinngemäß war die Aussage. Was für mich so ein bisschen darauf hindeutet, okay, man war sich relativ sicher, dass man den Kader zusammenstellen kann, der auf jeden Fall den Klassenerhalt schafft. Aber dass man vielleicht eben schon noch einen Tick höher guckt, vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, Platz 11, 10, 9. Und jede Platzierung in der zweiten Liga heißt ja dann auch jede Menge mehr Geld, die man dann im darauffolgenden Jahr durch die Fernsehennahmen bekommt. Und ich glaube, das war so ein bisschen das Ziel. Naja, man hat auf jeden Fall dann mit vielen Leistungsträgern aus der letzten Saison verlängert. Und das war jetzt in Rostock so ein bisschen neues Gefühl, weil du vorher so diesen Drittligar-Rhythmus hattest, alle Spieler unterschreiben für zwei Jahre. Und die Guten sind da wieder weg, die nicht so guten, die möchtest du selber tauschen. Und dass du jetzt das erste Mal das Gefühl hattest, okay, hier hast du jetzt einen Mannschaftskern, der vielleicht auch ein bisschen länger zusammen bleibt, punktuell verstärkt wird und dann eben, ja, sich peu à peu in dieser zweiten Bundesliga etabliert. Naja, dann war der Sommer, dann haben wir relativ überraschend Hanno Behrens verloren, der war letztes Jahr schon eine wichtige Stütze, fünf Tore gemacht, sechs Assists. Und Hansa war immer dann gut, wenn Behrens fit war. Zwischendurch war mal eine Phase, da hat er ein paar Spiele gefehlt. Das war die Phase, wo Hansa dann auch kaum gepunktet hat. Als er wieder da war, lief es plötzlich. Ja, dann hatten wir mit John Ferhug, haben wir immer noch, aber letzte Saison einen Stürmer, der 17 Tore gemacht hat, der aktuell eins hat. Und ja, da hat man sich vielleicht auch ein bisschen von blenden lassen oder ein bisschen darauf vertraut, dass man diese Quote wiederbekommt. So hat dann mit Lukas Hinterseher noch einen Stürmer dazu geholt, der aus meiner Sicht eins zu eins der identische Spielertyp ist. Der jetzt aber auch noch nicht so sonderlich viel Einsatzzeit hatte, hat immerhin aber schon zwei Tore gemacht. Naja, dann die höheren Ziele habe ich angesprochen. Aber wenn man jetzt mal so stand heute drauf guckt, gab es eigentlich kaum sinnvolle Transfers im Sommer. Wir haben – Moment – zwei Ersatztorhüter neu geholt. Relativ spät Rick van Drongelen bekommen, den würde ich als Verstärkung bezeichnen. Und dann muss ich schon ganz schön scrollen. Dennis Dressel ist noch dazu gekommen, der hat auch oft gespielt, der war sicherlich auch eine sinnvolle Ergänzung. Und Kai Pröger von Paderborn, der in der Hinrunde einige Tore gemacht hat, in der Rückrunde auch noch keins. Und das ist tatsächlich schon an den Spielern, wo ich sage, okay, die haben uns in irgendeiner Form verstärkt oder zumindest das Niveau, was wir vorher hatten, gehalten. Alle anderen sind leider Mitläufer, im besten Fall, oder im noch schlechteren Fall Ergänzungsspieler. So und dann beispielhaft sicherlich Sebastian Till, der mit viel Vorschusslorbeeren kam, der in Moldawien gespielt hatte, da auch Champions League gespielt hatte gegen Al-Madrid, mal gewonnen hat mit Sheriff Tiraspol. Und wo alle gedacht haben, wow, das ist ein Knaller. Und das ist vielleicht auch so derjenige der Hanno Behrens, der dann nach Indonesien gewechselt ist, zu Saisonbeginn ersetzen kann. Und das konnte er leider überhaupt nicht erfüllen. Warum weiß ich auch gar nicht so genau. Am Anfang der Saison war er verletzt und irgendwie ist er seitdem gar nicht mehr richtig reingekommen und war zuletzt meistens nicht mal im Kader, was ich persönlich irgendwie sehr schade finde. Ja, dann hast du in der Abwehr musstest du relativ oft umbauen. Hast du auch oft gewechselt zwischen 3er-5er und einer Viererkette. Hattest da wirklich verschiedene Formationen. Das hatte Verletzungsgründe, das hatte Formgründe. Aber insgesamt ist die Hansa-Abwehr nicht an diese Stärke herangekommen, die sie über die Jahre davor ausgezeichnet hat. Und das ist jetzt gerade in der Rückrunde das Problem. Naja, dann hast du die Winterpause einigermaßen verschenkt. Also im November, zwei Spieltage vor Ende der Hinrunde, wurde Jens Hertel dann beurlaubt. Und da muss ich auch sagen, das war irgendwie ein komisches Gefühl, weil Jens Hertel, den kannte ich ja schon aus Magdeburg, hatte da schon lange mit ihm zusammengearbeitet. So, dann ist er zu meinem Verein gewechselt und hat diesen Move, den er in Magdeburg ja schon gemacht hat, einfach wiederholt. Und ja, dass ich dann schon auch so irgendwie mal als Fan eben eine enge Bindung zu einem Trainer haben kann, die hatte ich zu Jens Hertel und würde sagen, das ist mein Trainer, also dem würde ich auch überall hinfolgen. Und dieses Gefühl hatten glaube ich viele Hansa-Fans und trotzdem ja auch befeuert durch diese Diskussion im Sommer. Und nachdem, wie die Spiele so in der Hinrunde liefen, hatte ich und hatten glaube ich viele schon das Gefühl, das geht irgendwie zu Ende. Aber man stand, glaube ich, bei der Entlassung auf Platz 12, hat aber punktemäßig ein bisschen überperformt, also gerade in den ersten Saisonspielen beim HSV gewonnen, gegen St. Pauli gewonnen, gegen Amina Bielefeld gewonnen, die ja damals noch als Absteiger aus der Bundesliga ein bisschen höher eingeschätzt wurden als das, was jetzt stand heute rausgekommen ist. Also aus den ersten fünf Spielen drei Siege. Das war ziemlich gut. Und danach waren relativ oft Spiele dabei. Ja, wenn Hansa in Rückstand geraten ist, hätte man das Spiel eigentlich auch abpfeifen können. Aber es gab immer noch so einen Sieg, dass man eben nicht unten gerutscht ist, dass man irgendwie den Abstand gehalten hat. Oder auch als Glöckner übernommen hatte zwei Spiele vor Ende, gab es einen Unentschieden gegen Nürnberg, gab es einen Sieg gegen Braunschweig. Und damit war man ja erstmal wieder im sicheren Hafen und konnte entspannt in die Winterpause gehen. Ja, dort wurde es dann verpasst, neue Spieler zu holen. Und das ist sicherlich ein Punkt, der Martin Piekenhagen auch sehr stark angelastet wurde. Und ich kann es einerseits verstehen, dass es es nicht gemacht hat, weil auch schon 30 Spieler im Kader sind. Und man ja, gerade nach der Rückrunde in der letzten Saison, schon auch, na ja, zumindest hoffen, vielleicht erwarten konnte, dass der Großteil der Spieler, die bewiesen hatten, dass wir absolut das Zweigliga-Format haben, das auch wieder auf den Platz bringen werden und entsprechende Ergebnisse einfahren werden. Das ist leider nicht passiert. So, dann musste Glöckner gehen. Und ja, dann kam eben Alois Schwarz. Und eine Sache ist mir jetzt gerade nebenbei noch aufgefallen, die ich so nachgeguckt hatte. Ja, keine Mannschaft außer Heidenheim, die da irgendwie eine krasse Abweichung haben, hat so eine Differenz zwischen Expected Goals und tatsächlichen Goals. Also, Hansa hat 30, 3 erwartete Tore, hat aber nur 23 geschossen. Also, ich sag mal, mit der Ausbeute, die wir vorhin gerade thematisiert hatten, hätten wir mit sieben Toren mehr, wahrscheinlich 15 Punkte mehr geholt. Würde ich jetzt mal so mich weit aus dem Fenster lehnen. Aber ja, und das zeigt eben auch, okay, es fehlt jetzt nicht nur an den Chancen, wobei es das oft auch ist, sondern es sind wirklich auch die, die man hart lässt man liegen. Und exemplarisch fällt mir da eben eine Szene aus dem Rückspiel gegen St. Pauli ein. St. Pauli schon über weite Strecken der ersten Hälfte dominiert. Zum Schluss Hansa ein, zwei Chancen gehabt. Und dann gab es in der zweiten Halbzeit eine Szene. Ball wird rausgespielt auf die rechte Seite. Moritz Schröter legt in die Mitte. John Verhoog völlig frei. Das war im Prinzip ein Elfmeter. Und der Torwart von St. Pauli schafft es irgendwie noch, den Ball zu halten. Und das war aus 100 Metern Entfernung, war das ein sicheres Tor. Und wo ich sage, letzte Saison hätte Johnny, wie wir ihn nennen, den auf jeden Fall reingemacht. Diese Saison machte den eben nicht. Und solche Situationen finden sich relativ oft. Ja, und dann wird es eben eng. Und deswegen steht der FC Hansa, da wo er steht.
Und was hat Ale Schwarz jetzt verändert? Und glaubst du, das kann noch reichen?
Da kann ich jetzt gar nicht so viel sagen. Also in der Abwehrformation wechselt er auch hin und her, wie ich es gesehen habe. Und zum Beispiel jetzt am Wochenende hat Magdeburg parallel gespielt und dann betreue ich ja noch den Halleschen FC, die haben auch noch parallel gespielt. Deswegen habe ich ehrlicherweise das Hansa-Spiel zur Halbzeit ausgemacht, weil Hansa war einer weniger. Und ich habe vermutet, dass es 0 zu 2 oder 0 zu 3 ausgehen wird. Und dann dachte ich, naja, dann nutze ich die Zeit lieber für meine Arbeitsmannschaften. Es kam leider genauso. Ja, ich weiß nicht, was mir negativ auffällt, ist, dass wir jetzt noch schlechter in der Abwehr sind. Also exemplarisch fällt mir das Spiel gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf ein. Das hatte ich mal so ein paar Minuten laufen lassen. Also ich muss dazu sagen, dass ich auch wirklich momentan oft schnell die Lust verliere, mir die Spiele anzugucken, wenn ich nicht selber da bin. Und dann war ich im Urlaub und dann habe ich immer so gedacht, du schaust mal rein und dann fallen in der Phase gerade irgendwie zwei oder drei Tore für den Gegner und dann mache ich wieder aus. So, aber gegen Düsseldorf waren das wirklich katastrophale Fehler und dann war jetzt das Spiel gegen Holstein-Kiel. Hansa führte relativ lange in der ersten Halbzeit 1-0 und kriegt dann kurz vor der Pause zwei Gegentore, weil sie sich wirklich da bei guter Strafraumbesetzung mit fünf, sechs Leuten im eigenen Strafraum da auf billigste Weise ausspielen lassen und dann die Gegentore bekommen. Also was ich mir eigentlich wirklich nur mit absoluter Verunsicherung erklären kann, dass du eben sagst, ja, so wie die ganze Rückrunde bis jetzt gelaufen ist, so wie da ein bisschen Gegenwind kommt, dann knickst du eben ein. Und deswegen ist mir jetzt tatsächlich noch nichts aufgefallen, was unter Alois Schwarz besser geworden ist.
Gut, man hat ja noch die direkten Duelle und dann, und noch gibt es ja auch die Tuchfühlung nach oben. Also die schlechte Rückrunde hat ja nicht verhindert, dass man absolut chancenlos wäre. Es sind zwei Punkte auf den Relegationsplatz, vier Punkte aufs rettende Ufer. Jetzt ist Rostock wahrscheinlich den Hörern und Hörern auch mal anders über den Weg gelaufen. Und das sind jetzt dann nicht sportliche Themen, die man hat. Also zum einen hat man immer wieder zum Teil offen Rechtsradikale oder Nazis, die man im Rostocker Fanumfeld sieht. Gerade natürlich auf St. Pauli wurde das auch sehr gut dokumentiert und war zu erkennen. Gleichzeitig gab es eine Image-Kampagne vom Verein. Ich glaube, das ist das, was vielen Hörern und Hörern über den Weg gelaufen ist, indem Spieler natürlich im Auftrag des Vereins sich dazu geäußert haben, keine Politik im Stadion ausüben zu wollen. Um es jetzt mal dezent zu formulieren, wirkt unglücklich auf mich. Wie schaust du auf das?
Ja, wenn wir es positiv formulieren wollen. Also die anderen Videos, das muss man vielleicht noch dazu sagen, waren – ich kriege es jetzt nicht mehr genau zusammen – keine Becherwürfe, keine Gewalt. Und dieses Thema Politik war, glaube ich, kein Rassismus, keine Politik. Die anderen beiden Sachen finde ich jetzt erst mal komplett ehrbar. Da habe ich nichts dagegen. Gegen keinen Rassismus habe ich auch überhaupt nichts.
Das Thema keine Politik ist natürlich – Es konterkariert vielleicht ein Teil dessen, was man zuerst gesagt hat.
Genau. Und ja, zielt sicherlich darauf ab, einfach irgendwie politische Diskussionen rechts, links, Anschuldigungen nenne ich es jetzt mal, du hast es gesagt, was da gegen St. Pauli auch teilweise zu sehen war, das einfach so ein bisschen rauszuhalten. Aber also richtig verstanden habe ich es auch nicht, weil einfach der Fußball und Fußballfans und das ganze Business natürlich auch extrem öffentlichkeitswirksam ist und extrem politisch in sehr vielen Feldern belastet ist. Oder ich weiß nicht, da fehlt mir gerade das richtige Wort, betroffen vielleicht. Insofern, ich habe es wirklich nicht verstanden, was man damit zusammenbringen wollte.
Und wie groß ist das Problem rechter Fans, die man hat?
Naja, das ist jetzt schwierig einzuschätzen. Also tatsächlich jetzt auch für mich als Fan. Weil ich auch sagen würde, es gab mal, das ist schon ein paar Jahre her, dass ein hoher NPD-Funktionär aus dem Stadion geflogen ist, weil Fans ihm signalisiert haben, dass sie ihn hier nicht dabei haben möchten. Du hast auch relativ bekannte Musikgruppierungen, wie Feine Sahne Fischfilet, die jetzt keiner irgendwie in die Nähe von Nazis rücken würde, vermute ich. Die zum FC Hansa gehen, die dort regelmäßig zu sehen sind. So viele meiner Freunde würde ich jetzt auch als eher Links einsortieren. Und trotzdem kann man natürlich nicht wegdiskutieren, dass es da sehr viel rechte Symbolik gibt, dass da auch offensichtlich der Nazis hingehen. Und ja, da gab es auch einen Konflikt, jetzt schon zwei, drei oder wahrscheinlich eher drei, vier Jahre durch Corona her, so die Süd-Tribüne als Stimmungsblock im Ostseestadion. Und da waren jetzt zehn Jahre lang alle Support-Filligen, sag ich mal, zu Hause. Und da ist ein Teil dann ausgezogen, ist auf die Nordtribüne gezogen. Und da sollen wohl auch Differenzen bei der politischen Ausrichtung eine Rolle gespielt haben. Andererseits, ja, wenn man das jetzt gegen St. Pauli gesehen hat, wie da eben sich Teile des Blogs präsentiert haben. Das waren sicherlich Leute aus beiden Blöcken, die da auch irgendwie eine Rolle gespielt haben. Deswegen würde ich jetzt sagen, Hansa ist kein Nazi-Verein. Aber man könnte sicherlich vorsichtig formuliert mehr tun, um diesem Bild in der Öffentlichkeit auch noch mehr entgegenzuwirken.
Und fällt mir das jetzt mehr auf, weil Hansa Rostock in der 2. Liga jetzt wieder ist und dann mehr darüber berichtet wird? Oder gab es da auch eine Entwicklung? Weil wir müssen ja nicht so tun, als ob das jetzt die einzigen Nazis wären, die irgendwo in Fußballstadien sind. Nee, das ist eher so tendenziell, finde ich, eine zunehmende Entwicklung, dass sich Rechte, die oft jetzt anders aussehen, anders sprechen und sich auch vor allem anders organisieren, sich wieder so reingesnickt haben in viele, in viele Stadien. Also da muss man jetzt gar nicht irgendwie extrem Beispiel Cottbus, sondern da kannst du auch zu Borussia Dortmund gucken, da kannst du auch hier beim FC Bayern gucken. Also überall hat man einfach so, wie wir in unserer Gesellschaft ja immer mehr eine Radikalisierung auch wahrnehmen und ja auch ein zunehmendes Antisemitismus. Ich habe heute gelesen, in München gab es im letzten Jahr 178 antisemitische Straftaten, also an jedem zweiten Tag eine im Jahr. Das ist einfach unfassbar, auf was wir uns da wieder zubewegen. Also ich möchte damit eben nicht sagen, nur Rostock und da ist es schlimm, aber es ist mir jetzt eben auch bei Rostock wieder besonders aufgefallen. Liegt das an der Aufmerksamkeit, die ich jetzt mehr habe, für Rostock und vielleicht auch manches Medium, weil es halt ein Zweitligist ist, oder gibt es da auch eine Entwicklung deiner Meinung nach?
Nee, ich glaube da gibt es schon eine Entwicklung, genau wie du es gesagt hast, gesamtgesellschaftlich und im gesamten Fußball, aber sicherlich und auch besonders beim FC Hansa ist da vieles wieder salonfähiger geworden, was es für vor 8 oder 10 Jahren vielleicht noch nicht war, wo man da sicherlich schon mal einen Schritt weiter war, wo ich jetzt auch das Gefühl habe und auch immer wieder Situationen tatsächlich im Stadion erlebe, wo ich denke, das wäre mir wahrscheinlich vor einer Weile nicht passiert, wo es jetzt auch wieder offensichtlicher zur Schau gestellt wird. Und da würde ich dir schon zustimmen bei deiner Einschätzung. Und das liegt nicht daran, dass Hans jetzt wieder 2. Bundesliga spielt, sondern, ja, das ist tatsächlich, denke ich, wer in der 3. Liga oder war auch teilweise in der 3. Liga, für mich schon genauso zu beobachten. Aber ja, da ist es dann vielleicht dir oder vielen anderen Fußballinteressierten ein bisschen verborgen geblieben, weil es dann doch nur in der 3.
Darf ich kurz eine Zwischenfrage stellen? Ich habe es auch immer wieder durch diverse Leute bei mir in der Timeline, die eben, ja, nicht nur die Fans, sich von den Fans distanzieren, die eben für sowas verantwortlich sind, sondern die auch ganz klar die Vereinführung kritisieren für, ja, im Prinzip was, also ich meine, das Video, über was wir gesprochen haben, oder über was ihr gesprochen habt, ist irgendwie so ein bisschen der negative Höhepunkt, aber es gab ja zu den Vorfällen auf St. Pauli, gab es ja Statements vom Verein, wo glaube ich gerade das erste irgendwie einen Zitat aus dem, wie man das auch nennen möchte, ich glaube aus der Vereinssatzung hat, irgendwie der FC Hansa ist nicht politisch so, dass dann irgendwie als Zitat aufgearbeitet wurde, dass das ja irgendwie überhaupt nicht sein kann, dass da irgendwie Rechte oder eine lichten Hagen irgendwie auch missbraucht wurde für, keine Ahnung, für Rechte, um sich gegen St. Pauli zu positionieren. Glaubst du, dass da einfach von der Vereinsführung vielleicht auch mehr kommen muss und dass deshalb vielleicht auch da zum Beispiel von mehr Fans halt der Fokus auch drauf ist, weil man dann irgendwie vom Verein dann einfach vielleicht als eben nicht Hansa-Fan, sondern als anderer auch eben zu wenig einen Widerspruch merkt?
Definitiv ja. Das plus der Punkt, wie formuliere ich das jetzt? Dass die Leute, sage ich mal, die zur Mitgliederversammlung in großer Zahl gehen, das ist nicht unbedingt die Mehrheitsmeinung im Verein. Das ist aber eben eine sehr lautstarke Gruppe und auch gut organisiert, so die dann entsprechend auch die Mitgliederversammlung beeinflussen kann. Und da sind jetzt, denke ich, viele Leute dabei, die für Dinge, die du gerade angesprochen hast, in irgendeiner Weise stehen oder die zumindest tolerieren, die da eben so ein bisschen die Stimmung vorgeben, so dass es da aktuell schwierig ist, für uns andere Mitglieder dagegen laut zu werden. Da fehlt auch ein bisschen der Organisationsgrad. Ich glaube, dass sich auch die Vereinsführung da ein bisschen versteckt oder das deutlich offensiver angehen könnte, aber da auch Angst vor dem internen Gegenwind hat und das deswegen nicht macht, so würde ich es mal formulieren.
Es ist halt schade. Es ist schwierig, darüber zu sprechen, weil Wittenberg ist nicht Paris. Ich stehe hier in München und kann dann sagen, Mensch, ihr müsst doch einfach keinen Fuß breiten den Faschisten und so weiter, weil ich es so auch denke, aber dann selbst in der Situation zu sein und entsprechend zu handeln ist schwierig. Und gleichzeitig ist es ja auch wahrscheinlich für dich eine schwierige Situation. Mir ist es unter anderem bewusst geworden, als ich mal mit Vereinsverantwortlichen von Dynamo Dresden gesprochen habe, wo ich auch eine sehr klare Meinung zu sehr vielen Sachen hatte, die Dresden-Fans getan und gesagt und gesungen und gebannert haben. Und da fand ich ganz viel davon einfach menschenverachtend und habe mir da auch ein entschiedeneres Vorgehen dagegen gewünscht. Und dann sprichst du mit Vereinsverantwortlichen. Also Dresden ist jetzt nicht Rostock, bei Rostock weiß ich nicht, wie es ist. Aber Dresden ist ja sogar dazu übergegangen, irgendwann eine Internetseite einzurichten, wo sie einfach nur alle Maßnahmen, die sie machen, von Info-Arten bis hin zu Soziale Arbeit usw. gegen Nazis, gegen Rassismus und Diskriminierung jeder Art auflisten, um zu sagen, wir versuchen es wirklich, aber wir haben einfach immer noch ein Problem mit solchen Fans. Und das ist ja auch für dich schwierig. Du bist Fan dieses Vereins, wir alle haben uns unseren Fußballverein nicht ausgesucht. Du weißt doch, dass es genügend andere Fans auch noch gibt. Du hast ja auch unter anderem ein paar Prominente schon genannt. Und trotzdem ist es eben ein Problem und es ist vielleicht sichtbarer als bei anderen Vereinen. Ich meine, die Bilder, die man da von der St. Pauli-Auswärtsfahrt gesehen hat, das ist schon einfach sehr eindeutig. Und wenn da dann auch irgendwelche verurteilten Nazis in der ersten Reihe stehen und man die identifizieren kann, da will ja auch niemand gegenandiskutieren. Und trotzdem stelle ich mir das jetzt einfach für dich ganz persönlich. Es ist eine sau-schwierige Situation, oder?
Definitiv. Wobei ich bei dem Thema verurteilte Nazis dachte, also ich möchte mit dem nichts zu tun haben. Das möchte ich ganz klarstellen. Aber da muss ich eben auch sagen, es ist 30 Jahre her, er ist verurteilt worden, hat aber dann auch seine Strafe irgendwo verbüßt. Das ist nicht, wie gesagt, ich kenne ihn nicht, ich möchte ihn jetzt nicht gutreden, aber das ist so ein Gedanke, der mir da durch den Kopf ging.
Ja, stimmt, hast du natürlich recht. Eigentlich sollten wir als Gesellschaft, man hat eine Haft auch dafür, dass man dann danach sagt, okay, jetzt bist du wieder integriert in die Gesellschaft, ja.
Ja, in der Theorie ja, aber da, wo er dann halt gestanden hat, vor dem lichten Hagenbanner, wofür er ja, glaube ich, verurteilt wurde, das ist halt der Kontext dann, wo man dann halt, glaube ich, in dem Fall da vielleicht ein bisschen anders argumentiert hat.
Sehe ich ja absolut in dem konkreten Fall auch so, war bloß ein Gedanke, der mir eben durch den Kopf geht, dass man eben sagt, okay, Straftäter irgendwie haben sie ihre Tat auch verbüßt und dürfen dann auch wieder zum Fußball fahren, so scheiße, wie man das finden kann. Zu dem Lichtenhagen-Banner, da muss ich vielleicht auch noch was sagen oder möchte ich was sagen. Ich meine, außerhalb von Rostock, würde ich jetzt behaupten, kennt man ja Lichtenhagen nur durch diese rassistischen Vorfälle 1992. So in Rostock ist das natürlich ein bisschen anders. Also ich bin jetzt kein gebürtiger Rostocker, aber meine Großeltern waren da, ich habe da einen Teil meiner Jugend verbracht und so weiter, würde sagen, dass ich mich in Rostock ganz gut auskenne. So und das ist einfach diese Sonnenblumenhäuser. Es gibt ja nicht nur eins. Die sind natürlich einfach das Kennzeichen für diesen Stadtteil. Und zumindestens mir geht es so, wenn ich in Rostock unterwegs bin mit der S-Bahn, vom Stadtzentrum nach Warnemünde, da gibt es verschiedene Neubaugebiete, die man beim Blick aus dem Fenster an irgendwas erkennt. So bei einem Lüttenglein ist es der Igerpark, beim anderen Lichtenhagen sind es eben die Sonnenblumenhäuser. Und auch da wohnen meines Wissens ganz normal Leute drin, auch nicht wenige, sondern in dem ganzen Plattenbaugebiet wohnen ein paar tausend Leute. Und deswegen finde ich es erstmal nicht verwerflich, muss ich sagen, dass es dieses Banner gibt. Also das wurde ja, habe ich teilweise in Diskussionen schon gelesen, ja wie kann man überhaupt so ein Banner produzieren? Da würde ich jetzt einfach erstmal sagen, es würde Leuten zugestehen, die da wohnen, die ihren Stadtteil mögen, dass sie sich eine Fahne malen, wo ihr Stadtteil drauf steht. So, das zweite ist aber natürlich, wie das eingesetzt wird. Das ist aus meiner Sicht eine absolute Katastrophe. Und noch viel schlimmer ist, dass es eben zweimal jetzt in dieser Saison passiert ist. Und eben, dass es dann gut sichtbar Richtung der St. Pauli-Fans hängt, dass eben da bestimmte Leute auch noch direkt sichtbar dahinterstehen, dass dann wie im Gästeblog in St. Pauli da überall noch Sonnenblumen aufgehängt werden. Ja, und dann eben um die maximale Provokation sozusagen auf dem Rücken von Opfern rassistischer Gewalt zu erzielen. Und ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich so das Hauptproblem, dass man als Hansa-Fan, unabhängig von der politischen Einstellung, also dass es Gruppen bei Hansa gibt, die einfach extrem auffallen wollen und extrem provozieren wollen. Und dass dazu eben gefühlt jedes Mittel recht ist. Und das ist auch schon eine ganze Weile so, dass gefühlt bei jedem Auswärtsspiel die Klos zerstört werden. Also es müssen Leute irgendwie rumlaufen und die ganze Woche denken, geil, am Wochenende fahre ich nach Groß-Aßbach oder nach Wiesbaden oder zum Hamburger SV und kann endlich wieder Toiletten zerlatschen. So was mir wirklich nicht in den Kopf will, aber offenbar gibt es solche Leute. Und dann will man eben da auch gerade dadurch, dass man glaube ich lange nicht in der deutschen oder so im Fokusstand im deutschen Fußball dadurch auffallend, dass man einfach extrem ist. Und ja, das merkt man eben auch am Verhalten so. Ich möchte noch mal sagen, diese Provokation, das lehne ich absolut ab, das ist eine absolute Katastrophe und glaube aber, dass das einfach so das Interesse vieler ist, maximal zu provozieren, egal womit am Ende. Hauptsache man findet irgendwas, womit man dem Gegner richtig doll auf die Nerven gehen kann.
Männliche Fußballfans, man muss sie einfach lieben. Und ich glaube, man kann es auch wieder aus Geschlecht runterbrechen. Zumindest, na wobei, wer weiß ja, ob da einzelne Frauen mit dabei sind. Aber das Verhalten ist dann doch ein eher männlich kodiertes. Ich glaube, so können wir es stehen lassen, auch wenn ich noch keine Toilette ausmache.
Naja, ein anderer Punkt, der bei uns ja, also der gegen Hansa regelmäßig hervorgekrampft wird, ist ja Plakate, die tatsächlich existieren. Wo drauf steht, hier kein Instagram, kein YouTube, bla bla bla, und keine Frauen in den ersten drei Reihen. Also das ist ja, ist jetzt tatsächlich keine Erfindung, die gibt es tatsächlich. Und insofern können wir da schon sagen, dann sind das sicherlich die Männer in den ersten drei Reihen, ja. Oder vier oder fünf leider.
Aber absolut. Aber ich fand's jetzt wichtig, da auch nochmal drüber zu reden. Und es ist, glaube ich, nämlich vor allem auch wichtig, anlasslos drüber zu reden. Also eben nicht, wenn der große Aufreger passiert, den es eben dann gibt. Und der ja auch etwas provozieren soll. Du hast das, finde ich, gerade ganz gut erklärt. Da habe ich nämlich dann auch manchmal das Gefühl, also so richtig ich es immer finde, sich gegen Nazis zu positionieren und das auch zu problematisieren. Aber manchmal habe ich dennoch den Eindruck, da reiben sich manche dann doch auch ihre ansonsten immer ausgestreckten Fäustchen und freuen sich, dass genau das nämlich passiert ist. Nämlich, dass sich eben dann die linke Bubble oder eigentlich die normale Bubble sollte es eigentlich sein. Aber es ist dann doch eher die linke Bubble, sich drüber aufregt. Deswegen finde ich es jetzt eben auch wichtig, jetzt einfach mal, wo in Anführungszeichen nichts Konkretes gerade passiert ist, mal drüber zu sprechen. Weil genau das müssen wir ja machen. Wir müssen da hingucken. Und das eben nicht nur in Rostock, sondern ich habe es jetzt hier auch schon mehrfach gesagt, auch noch bei genügend anderen Vereinen. Es gibt da ganz bedenkliche Tendenzen in Deutschland. Da müssen wir uns gegen positionieren. So, das ist jetzt irgendwie der Schluss dieser Sendung, keine Ahnung. Aber ich will da jetzt auch keine lustige Überleitung machen. Ich sage einfach Danke, dass ihr mit mir auf die Liga geblickt habt und auf eure drei Vereine. Und dann wissen wir ja, zumindest im Tabellenkeller wird es definitiv spannend bleiben, so eng, wie das alles beieinander ist. Und wer weiß, ob Lukas sich vielleicht wirklich noch einschalten kann ins Aufstiegsrennen, sollte St. Pauli gegen HSV unentschieden ausgehen. Dann können wir uns davon sicher sein. Lukas, du hast es uns quasi versprochen. Deswegen, wir werden dich an deinen Worten messen. Das hat man vorhin schon so ein bisschen rausgehört. Also dieses Spiel, das ja eh schon an sich schon spannend genug wäre. Es hat jetzt noch einmal auch mal eine überraschende Düsseldorf-Komponente bekommen, möchte ich dazu sagen. Und für die danke ich dir und dafür, dass du hier warst. Ich möchte nochmal euren Podcast empfehlen. Aus dem Exil heißt ja, da bekommt man natürlich noch viel, viel mehr Informationen zur Fortuna. Danke, lieber Lukas, dass du mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk warst. Und dann danke ich Eva-Lotta Bohle, der at eva-bole. Und bei mastodon.social ist sie natürlich auch. Wie schnell ich lerne. Schön, Eva, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst.
Ja, vielen Dank wie immer für die Einladung. Und ich merke mir das jetzt auch, wie man das korrekt sagt, mit dem at mastodon. Das hat schon damals sehr lange gedauert mit Tuta. Ich verspreche dir auch, ich mache das nicht wie Tuta, dass ich immer mittendrin meinen Nutzen habe.
Ja, stimmt, genau, das gab es ja auch noch. Schon wieder ganz, ganz verändert. Aber er wurde ja einfacher auszusprechen. Das ist ja fast so wie bei einem uns beiden bekannten Fürther-Journalisten. Also danke, dass du hier warst. Und ich danke auch Oliver Leiste, der at leisteo auf Twitter. Danke dir, Oli, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk. Nach deinem Training noch, meine Güte, du musst doch jetzt richtig müde sein.
Also, dass weder das Training noch der Rasenfunk sind das, was diese Woche anstrengend machen, aber auch das wird vorbei gehen. Nee, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank, dass ich hier sein durfte. Hat wieder sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ich freue mich, wenn wir das nächste Mal reden, dass dann die sportliche und die Fansituation beim FC Hansa etwas besser ist. Eva, wo wir gerade bei der richtigen Aussprache sind. Ich glaube, ich werde sonst gemaßregelt, wenn ich dir das komplett durchgehen lasse.
Ich versuche, jedes Mal zu merken.
Ich habe eine Tasse zugeschickt bekommen, als ich es falsch gemacht habe. Also, deswegen, man darf falsch machen, dann kriegt man Tassen zugeschickt. Ich habe auch vorhin Paderborn ganz komisch ausgesprochen.
Vielleicht kriege ich da jetzt auch eine Tasse zugeschickt. Ich möchte keine Paderborn-Tasse.
Ja, du kannst es ja auch mal aussprechen.
Wenn du möchtest, organisiere ich dir eine FCM-Tasse.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst, ich werde enterbt, wenn das passiert.
Ich habe hier Bielefeldkrug bei mir im Geschirrschrank stehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie der hierher gekommen ist.
Und ich wurde auch richtig enttäuscht.
Ja, habe ich wirklich keine Idee. Na gut, also ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, nochmal verbunden mit dem Appell. Empfehlt den Rasenfunk weiter. Sagt den Leuten, dass wir auch regelmäßig Sendungen zur 2. Männer-Bundesliga machen. Und hört natürlich auch unsere anderen Formate zur 1. Männer-Bundesliga, zur Frauen-Bundesliga und zum Internationalen Männerfußball. Also es gibt wirklich viel zu hören im Rasenfunk. Bitte empfehlt uns weiter. Und bitte unterstützt uns auf rasenfunk.de slash supportersclub erfahrt ihr wie. Und dann hören wir uns hier wieder, wenn ihr mögt, in der nächsten Sendung. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, macht's gut, ciao.